- I love Daft Punk.
I'm just like, wow, the noise sounds nice.
Like I like the noise,
you know what I mean?
Is that weird?
(laughs)
- Yes, it is weird.
- Am I weird?
- It is very weird, yeah.
- I know I think you just
basically described music
in the most like, bare
bones monkey brain terms.
(laughs)
- It is a bunch of noises put together.
(upbeat music)
- Do your parents like,
watch "Trash Taste"?
- Yes.
- And they comment on every
little thing you do now?
- My mum told me that
like, to stop putting
my hand near my face
and for the past like
five episodes I've tried
to avoid putting my hands
anywhere near my mouth.
- Yeah, my mum's like, "Oh
you wore shorts this episode.
The entire world knows you're
wearing shorts this episode,
by the way, why are you wearing shorts?"
- How does she know that?
Your legs don't show.
- I didn't know either
but apparently on camera they showed it
when I sat on this side, so.
- She's like, "Enhance, enhance."
My mum gave me shit whenever I was saying
that British food is awful,
you know.
(laughs)
I was neglected growing up
'cause I was fed beans on toast often.
It's true though, mum.
But anyway, welcome to this
episode of Trash Taste.
I'm your boy, Connor.
(laughs)
I forgot what I'm supposed to say.
- I'm your boy.
- I'm your boy because I couldn't figure
the rest of the words.
- It's your boy.
(laughs)
- I'm with the boy,
that's it.
And the other boy.
- And together we are "The Boys".
- "The Boys".
That was, had to be
one of the best intros.
- Yeah.
- I just, you know, when you're
like auto-piloting the intro
and then you just realize halfway through
that you're auto-piloting the intro,
and then you're like taking it over
and you're like, oh wait, I
should have just auto-piloted.
- 'Cause like, being on a podcast,
normally if I'm having a
normal conversation sometimes
and I know like, sometimes I
know when I start a sentence,
I know how I'm gonna end the sentence
but when you're on a podcast,
you always have to finish the sentence
even if you kind of
realize halfway through
that you're not making any sense.
- Yeah I'm just like, okay,
I'm gonna have to say something
because I've been silent
for the past two minutes
but I don't know how to
start it or how to end it,
where this is going.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you're right, you're right.
(laughs)
- So gentlemen, I thought, considering
I believe we all watched
"Japan Sinks" recently.
- That was a nice little coinkydink there.
- Yeah.
- And we all watched it separately,
I didn't know you guys were watching it.
- We didn't make an
effort to all watch it.
We all just like, oh,
we all just watched...
- We all just turned on Netflix
and was like, "Oh, okay it's on, cool."
- And it came out recently
at the time of recording
but so by the time you are
seeing this might not be.
- I think it was only like,
three or four days ago.
- Yeah.
- Something like that?
- Yeah, yeah for us but--
- So to explain what "Japan Sinks" is
since we're gonna be doing
some kind of discussion around it,
it's the new Masaaki Yuasa anime
that was released on Netflix
and it's basically
about a giant earthquake
that happens in Japan
and after that earthquake happened,
Japan starts sinking I guess.
- Yeah, so for people living in Japan,
it is anxiety the anime, essentially.
- Dude, okay, first of all
before we get into talking it,
in the very first episode
they play the actual--
- The sound they played.
The earthquake sound.
(alarm blares)
This sound that you're hearing here.
- Did we like, I don't
know if it's just me.
- I checked my phone immediately.
- Yeah, I checked my phone.
I was like, where's my phone?
(laughs)
- And I turned that shit
down 'cause I was like,
Fuck, what if my neighbors hear?
And start freaking out
like, they're gonna think
there's an actual earthquake.
They're elderly you know, below me
but that made me shit myself.
- That gave me so much anxiety.
- The first episode of them portraying
the earthquake happening,
I was really impressed
at how realistic it felt.
You know what I mean,
'cause I probably would have
reacted the exact same way
as all the characters, right.
You know when you hear that
earthquake notification now
and then you just kind of block it out,
oh whatever, it's probably
a small earthquake.
'cause once you've been through
about 10 earthquakes in Japan--
- Which you will.
- Yeah, which you will.
You just hear this notification
and it's just like another day of the--
- Unfortunately though, every
time at least I have heard
that notification, it's never been
the case of, whatever,
it's probably just a small earthquake,
because it always happens
at like five in the morning
and it's the thing I wake up to.
Imagine just having,
you're just having a nice
sleep wherever you are
and it's like 4:30 in the morning
and then suddenly you hear
this absolutely anxiety-inducing alarm
because you just hear the siren
but they don't say like, if it's strong
or if it's weak.
- It just says brace yourself.
- Yeah.
- Just basically brace yourself.
(Connor imitates alarm)
- Hold on to your bike, it might be strong
and I already hate waking
up to the sound of an alarm
but when it's an alarm where
it's like, oh I might die,
then it's the worst.
I had, I was enjoying
the first episode so much
because again, there was
this, you know, as you said,
it's a really realistic portrayal
but the moment I hear that
sound, I just, I don't know.
I don't get anxiety often but--
- I went like the Caveman SpongeBob meme.
(laughs)
And they do it like three times.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, stop doing this.
Please use a like, parody
noise or something like...
- Could you imagine though like,
especially in that
first episode, you know,
when that second big wave hits.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Do you think something
like that is going to happen?
- Well, in the, it's like a lot of,
again, I should have done
research for this episode
but I swear there's been a
few scientific predictions
that are like, there's gonna be
a mega quake within like 30 or 50 years.
- [Garnt] Something like that.
- I mean, there has to be, right.
Because I mean the fucking
planets, not planets,
the countries all Pangaead away, right.
That doesn't just happen.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- There has to be stuff
that's moving constantly.
So inevitably something
big is gonna happen.
- Inevitably, whether it's in our lifetime
or like, our children's lifetime
or fucking great, great, great
grandchildren's lifetime,
it's gonna happen some way.
- Like a mega quake, yeah.
- Like a mega quake, you know.
It's an interesting idea to explore
that there's probably gonna be
some massive kind of
event that's gonna happen
some time in the--
- Because is there like,
I don't know about,
I'm sure Thailand has earthquakes, right.
- Not really.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- I mean, Japan is
literally on the fault line.
Like, the whole country's
on the fault line.
- Like, do you guys remember
your very first earthquake experience?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that was okay, we're from the UK.
Like, it is literally the
safest place on earth.
- I was about to say, you guys
don't get earthquakes, right?
- No, no, we're like the furthest away
from any fault line of like any country...
- We were like, natural
disasters in the UK
is like, non existent.
- It's like running out of tea.
- Like in England, England
is so fucking safe.
You have to try really
hard to get yourself killed
in England by nature.
(laughs)
- Yeah, you really do have
to go out of your way.
- Yeah, because Australia, we
don't have earthquakes at all
or anything like that.
- But everything else will just kill you.
- Yeah, but we have you know, bush fires
and stuff like that and
of course our animals
are just out for blood
but you guys don't even have
dangerous animals, right?
- No, we don't.
- That's why I'm convinced
there's so many like,
famous British explorers because they must
have been so fucking bored of the UK.
(laughs)
Like, "Oh, it's another fucking squirrel,
who'd have thought?"
- Like, "It's a bigger squirrel."
- Talking to Americans and
Canadians who go camping
and they have to worry about
bears and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- I remember going camping in England
and I'm just like, oh
yeah, I guess we have
to worry about deers.
Like, deers can be dangerous.
- I feel like the biggest worry in the UK
is how much alcohol do I bring?
(laughs)
Like how much alcohol is
the right amount of alcohol?
- How much alcohol and
toilet paper do I bring?
- That's always the worry
'cause it's like, I've got
to carry two liters of water,
10 liters of alcohol.
So we gotta like try and
balance this out somehow.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, I remember
my very first earthquake
experience, wasn't in Japan,
it was actually in America during AX28.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- Oh, last year?
- AX 28, well not last year now.
Oh no, it is last year.
- Last year, yeah.
- Yeah last year's AX, so 2019 AX
and I remember, I remember--
- That was your first one?
- Yeah, that was my very first one.
- Yeah, that was my first one as well.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah.
- So yeah, to explain, when
we were at AX last year,
we went through a magnitude,
is it seven earthquake?
- It was six or seven.
- But it was far away, so it wasn't awful
but it was still, I mean, we were...
- It still is the strongest
earthquake I've been in.
even after moving Japan
and I remember I was on like
the 64th floor or something.
- Yeah, we all were.
- And it was like, such
a humbling experience
because at first I didn't
know what was going on.
'Cause I remember standing
up and I felt a bit dizzy
and I was like, what the fuck's going on?
Am I just like really fatigued,
am I hung over, what's going on?
So I go up to the window, right.
Just imagine you're going up
to the window on the 64th
floor of a skyscraper
and then you look down
and then you see the fucking
building just shift like that
and it was just like this.
(laughs)
Like I immediately, I've
never felt vertical so fast
and I immediately just pinned
myself against the wall,
just being like, shit,
shit, this is an earthquake.
- I'm surprised you had the
balls to go towards the window.
- 'Cause I didn't know
it was an earthquake.
I just thought I was just
dizzy or drunk or something.
- I mean, the first one
'cause there was like,
three that weekend, was there?
- No, no, there was two.
- There was two in the, it was
in the same day, wasn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, so the first one,
I was in the elevator
while it was happening.
- [Joey] Oh, my God.
- And the elevator was shaking
a lot more than I thought
it should have been shaking
and I'm pretty sure there was
a Japanese woman in there who
was from one of the stands
and she looked fucking
terrified and I was like,
we're nearly near the bottom,
I'm sure it will be fine.
(laughs)
We're like 10 floors, I'm sure we got this
but then the second one was I
was with you. That was so fun.
- Do you wanna tell that story?
- You should tell it, you should.
- Okay, okay, so the second
earthquake that happened,
I think it was only maybe a couple
of hours after, wasn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, I think it was like--
- I think we just rushed
to your hotel room
'cause I was busy.
- That's right, that's right.
- That was like, that night.
- Yeah, it was you, me,
Arcy and our friend, Navi
and we were just chilling in a hotel room,
we were just talking about
what were we gonna do that night
'cause I think it was the--
- We were going to go to a party.
- We were gonna go to a party
and so we were just chilling
before the party started
and you know, the second
earthquake comes through
and it was, I think it was
stronger than the first one, wasn't it?
- I think so.
- Something like that but
either way, very strongly,
at least magnitude six
from what I remember.
- I think it was the 7.1 that earthquake.
- Yeah, I think that was
the seven, wasn't it?
- Yeah, and of course it was
an earthquake, I'm used to it,
obviously everybody else wasn't.
So we quickly ran out and we were at the
very, very top of it, I
think it was like the 68th
or 69th floor or something
of that hotel and,
(laughs)
and even amidst all the panic,
Connor and my friend Navi,
they were eating a...
- I was eating Chick-fil-A.
- Chick-fil-A like,
(laughs)
Chick-fil-A nuggets and Connor
and Navi just kind of looked
at each other and went,
well, if I'm gonna die,
might as well finish off these nuggets.
(laughs)
- Like everyone was panicking.
I remember there was literally
that like stereotypical American family,
it was one like, white
guy with three daughters,
he's like, "Get down to the floor,
get down to the bottom floor daughters,
I'm gonna direct you."
And I'm there with like,
my nuggets walking past him
slowly like, I mean, it's fine.
I got about, yeah, go on, go on.
- If I'm gonna die, at least I'm gonna die
with nugs in my hands.
- Yeah, exactly.
(laughs)
- We were like, rushing down the stairs,
we got like 20 floors down
and I was like, I'm not, you know what,
I don't want to do any
more physical exercise.
I think, I think I've done enough, so.
I did a move, which is
probably not a pro gamer move.
I was like, you know what,
the shaking stopped like two minutes ago.
I'm gonna get the elevator.
(laughs)
There is 50 more floors and
I would rather die literally,
than get these stairs and
I went to the elevator
but the weird configuration of this hotel,
you had to go back to the top.
- [Joey] Yeah, to go down again, yeah.
- So that means then
I was like, all right,
well the elevators are still working.
They should have been stopped,
they were still working.
So I was like, okay,
so I go back from the 50th
floor, which I just walked out
from the 70th to the 50th,
I walked all the way down
and I was like, okay,
I'm going to go back up
to the 70th floor.
I go to get the elevator
to go all the way down
and they're blocking it off.
They're like, you can't go until it's safe
and I'm like, fuck.
- Meanwhile our other friend
was just like, fuck it,
I'm gonna walk all the way down.
He sprinted all the way down
and he's just waiting at the bottom
and he calls me, he's
like, "Are you guys alive?"
- 'Cause I convinced them, I'm like,
listen guys, you guys can keep walking.
I'm getting the elevator
and then they were like,
"Okay, well we'll come."
- No, I came with you, I remember.
I was like, well, great, we're back.
I guess we ran down 20
floors for no reason.
- It was so scary though 'cause
I remember I was a little,
I wasn't worried because you
know, the doors were closing
and opening on their own.
I thought that's okay,
I can deal with that.
What I didn't like, anticipate was
when I looked out the building,
I could literally see
the building opposite us,
we were going like this.
We were like parallaxing
and I was like, oh that's not right.
(laughs)
That's not good.
- Like buildings shouldn't do that.
No, 'cause I remember it was like, to me,
it was a really humbling experience.
Just at that moment, I was like,
my life is not in my own hands.
Like, if this building collapses,
there is literally nothing I can do
'cause you know when you feel
like something bad happens,
you feel like you have
some, some kind of control.
Like you might see a car
coming and you think,
maybe I can jump out of the way of this.
There was like, if the
building was just not designed,
like logically I knew this building was
designed to withstand earthquakes
but in my heart I was
like, okay at this moment,
I'm just putting my faith in the engineers
and the builders that they've done
their job fucking correctly,
'cause if they haven't, I'm dead.
And there's literally
nothing I can do about it
and I guess that was like
a first for me, you know.
I'd never been in that kind
of situation where I had just,
my life was in the hands of
like completely something,
some other external--
- To be fair, I've experienced
a lot of earthquakes in my life but
being on the 69th, 70th floor
was different at first for me.
You know, I've been on,
you know, apart, I've been
in apartment buildings that
are like 10, 20 floors high
and that was still scary because again
the whole thing is shaking.
I have to keep telling myself
it's good that it's shaking,
it's good that it's shaking.
But my first I think
the scariest earthquake
experience I had was it
was in Japan obviously
and it was up North
where my grandma lives.
- Right.
- And it was where, you
know the giant earthquake
of 2011 hit essentially.
So that is, that plays like a hotspot
of massive earthquakes.
And, and I was there, I
was in some kind of like
DVD rental place.
There's like a really old DVD rental place
near there with my sister
and suddenly I think it was like
a magnitude seven and a half.
Something like that, really, really big.
It was so big in fact that all
of the DVDs and books on
the shelves just flew out.
- Oh, wow.
- And me and I had to
like grab my sister's hand
and just fucking get
the hell out of there.
- Wow.
- And, but we couldn't go all the way out
because the shop assistant was like,
"Don't go out into the street."
because if a sheet
falls, then you're dead.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So we had to kind of stand
in the doorframe of the shop
and just kind of wait
for it to settle down.
And yeah, that was definitely
a little scary because
it being on the, I thought
being on a building was scary,
being on the ground
for like on the street,
in something that big is really scary.
- Yeah, 'cause people are running out
and I thought that's kind of dumb
'cause the building's really safe.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And running out you
don't know what could like.
- Could fall on you.
- Exactly,
if a traffic light or a,
you know a street light
falls on you, then, you know.
- I think it's just, it's
that sense of control.
You know, they think you have, even though
statistically you, you are
actually safer in the building.
- Yeah, the buildings are
designed at least the newer ones,
I think like, I mean
that a really big hotel
and it's mainly designed for
like 13 magnitude earthquake.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They're pretty steady.
- Speaking of sense of control though
the characters in "Japan Sinks" have none.
(laughs)
Oh my God, can we go back to that?
- Yeah, are we gonna spoil things,
this gonna be the first spoiler
warning that we need to do.
- We have had a spoiler warning before.
- Okay, well there'll be a
spoiler warning on screen.
We're gonna spoil things, I guess.
- It's only 10 episodes, it's on Netflix,
go watch it, it's great.
- If you don't care about being
spoiled, feel free to watch.
I hate the main girl so much.
I could not stand her.
- I don't mind her at first
but then when she started
to get a bit wingy later on,
- Can I, can I just to get my to get
my opinions out of the way,
what'd you guys think
of the series overall?
- I'm glad that we finally have some
good propaganda for YouTubers,
like is I'm glad that we
need more YouTube propaganda.
YouTube is a good guys.
- We need more YouTube, characters.
- I'm so glad and I was like, wow
he's a YouTuber and he's not
an asshole, this is amazing.
- No, no, no 'cause, cause.
- This is amazing.
- Okay, so there's a character in,
in "Japan Sinks" that is just a YouTuber.
and he's a YouTuber who's
a fucking superhuman
'cause he can do everything.
- He's mad...
- Why did he get a tank from?
(laughs) Where did the tank come from?
We're just not gonna explain
where he got a tank from?
- I love how,
it's not even that but
like the way that he enters
in that fan propelled.
- Yeah, I know.
- And he's just like, yeah, this is mine.
I bought it with my YouTube ad.
And it's like, what
videos are you uploading?
- Really telling me, you're going to film
a video of Okinawa sinking
and that shit's gonna be monetized.
(laughs)
Come on,
millions of people died,
monetized, fuck off, no way.
- Can we just appreciate
that the character
is basically Felix, beautify
for he just have like a.
- He's like wide head Felix.
(laughs)
Like the time when Felix had
the really, really blonde hair.
- Yes, I remember when I met Felix
and when he came in on his.
(murmurs)
- It's like the idealized
vision of PewDiePie
like this is his final form, right.
This is rock scene.
- How we see PewDiePie..
- I wouldn't, I wouldn't be surprised
if he changes his profile
picture to that character next
because it was really from.
- Yeah.
- For the longest time.
- It's real, it's real.
- It's real, it looks like real.
Yeah, but I guess when I
saw that and as you said,
it was probably one of the first times
that a YouTube has been kind of viewed
a lot more of a positive life.
- Any form of
a positive fashion.
- Yeah, it really goes
to show me that I think
most like Yuasa's fan of YouTube.
- Yeah, it just, it just disappointed me
that in his final scene, he didn't,
he didn't send them off by going.
Don't forget to like and subscribe.
(laughs)
- Yeah, very unrealistic.
There was never a pull,
there was not one sponsorship
in the whole thing, come on.
No raid shutters.
(laughs)
- I wanna imagine, him flying away,
him flying away like
freezing half to death
through the stratosphere and he's like,
splits marriage...
(laughs)
- Very unrealistic YouTuber.
Okay, I'm gonna, what, out of 10,
was it, was it good or bad?
What are you guys?
- Okay, I'm not going
to say that it was a 10.
I'm gonna give it like a solid seven.
- I thought it was like a four or five.
- Really, you didn't like it?
- No, I didn't like it
either, okay here's my...
- I couldn't stop watching it
but I didn't, I had so have
so many things I hated.
- Right.
- Okay, here's the thing this,
the way, this is like a
proper mixed bag for me.
- [Connor] Yeah, same.
- The way I would describe it is that
it's a four out of 10 series
with some 10 out of 10 scenes.
- [Connor] Okay, that's fair, that's fair.
- It was really weird 'cause some scenes
were fucking amazing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was like (murmurs).
- First two episodes, absolute bangers.
- No, exactly, and like some of the scenes
are like the last episodes,
absolute bangers as well.
Like, like the sea in the
scenes where the YouTuber
and like some, some of the death scenes.
- Oh the scene where the
guy's running on the thing?
- Yeah, yeah, I don't know
why Yuasa has about making
emotional running scenes.
- Yeah.
- But it's a...
- And the father's death
completely caught me off guard.
- [Joey] Yeah, too.
- And that ruined me.
- And I was like, oh
cool, the one character
I liked is dead, in episode to.
- Yeah, I looked for
thought like, wow, this
like after I finished
episode two, I thought
like this could be a 10 out of 10
if they keep off with like
how good this is, and then.
- And then we went into the cult.
- And then we go to the cult,
and I was like, oh no, this is awful.
This is actually awful.
Like the cult arc for
me was so bittersweet
because as a massive fan of Yuasa's stuff,
I'm like, oh this is so Yuasa.
- There's a scene when.
- What the fuck was the cult,
what the fuck was it?
- Okay, you gotta meet the 360...
- That was amazing.
- That wasn't the part where I loved most,
the part I loved most was...
- When the kid die.
(laughs)
- I was just watching a dead series
and the kid just gets fucking
destroyed by this rock
and I literally just let
out, like a (laughs).
- He was just like, he was
so perfect comedic timing.
He was just, he turns around, he's like,
(in foreign language)
- It was like slap stick...what was that.
- He was, 'cause I remember
I was like properly,
I was properly invested in the series.
My first few episodes
I'd properly invested
and then like some things
just fell off like as,
as the, as the series went on, right.
'Cause like I remember their father dying
and it was, he died in a
really horrific fucking way.
- Yeah.
- And then nobody really
just acknowledged that.
They had like, they had like
- It just cuts, doesn't it.
- Yeah, they had like
one conversation, oh,
you're a forgetting dad
and then they just like, next even
and like happy go lucky,
shopping in a supermarket.
And I'm just like, like if that was real
I wouldn't be able to say anything
for like the next five days.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Let alone even think about.
- And yet, for some reason,
every other character
that dies off of that, they have like
a full on emotional scene.
That just drags out
like crazy, right, yeah.
- Yeah, something just felt
off about the character.
I don't know what it was about
how they were written but
it just didn't like
sometimes they acted the way
I would imagine people
would act and sometimes
they just acted in a
completely random way.
- Yeah.
- And then the cult arc
happened and I was like, okay
okay, now, now we've gone
from something feels off
to this is just stupid.
So much needed explaining
about that, like whole thing.
Where were they getting
all of this food from?
- Where they getting all of the weed?
- So much weed.
- Just fields of weed.
- Like in Japan, you just
gonna grow fields of weed.
- Also they never explained
that fact that like the,
the grounds where the
cult stood wasn't affected
by the tilting continental shift.
- There's just so much,
there's so much stuff,
when it got to the cult
arc where I was like,
this is too much, too many
holes for me to just like,
be like, this is okay 'cause...
- At the end of it all
I think the only reason,
I was trying to figure out, okay.
What was the point of this cult arc?
Like, like what were they trying to build
and I think the only thing
that came out of this cult arc
was just the fact that they got that
Morse code talking professor
out of there, right.
- But why was he there?
None of this was explained.
- It was just a slapstick comedy.
- It was.
- Like, like I remember
watching the co-talk
and you know that points
when you like really invested
in the show and then,
you go from being
invested to just laughing
at how bad it's become.
That was the co-talk for me
and I couldn't get invested
back into the show after that.
- Yeah, it hurt too much
after the cult arc happened
and the fact that they just realize,
okay, if the old man is
addicted to morphine,
I'm fine with that but
they didn't even build up
to that at all.
They could have showed
some kind of, you know
like they could've maybe
showed him taking some pills.
- The fact that the old man shot that kid
at the end of episode four, three.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then they were like, and then,
and then he was like oh,
I'm sorry and whatever.
- I didn't mean to show you,
let me fix your game boy.
- Dude you just fucking shot my kid
with the intent to kill him.
He's like, if he didn't
have his fucking DS,
like he would be dead.
So you're just gonna let him hang around.
- That was actually the last PS Vita.
- And to be fair though,
at the end of episode four
when the kid got shot, I was
like, oh, thank God, he's dead.
My God, that kid was fucking annoying.
- Okay, did you watch "The Dubbed"?
- I watch both.
- I watch some.
- Lik I literally, I
was like I watched dub,
something fell off I watched the sub
and full of first time on my fucking life,
I could not stand like
the voice siting in the...
- No, it was really, like I get it
that they're supposed to
be like native and both
but then I feel like
they should've got people
who are native and both, it's doable.
Because when they whenever he said,
let's go, it's just like that's not.
- Yeah, it sounds really off.
- Dad.
- Or they could have even have just gotten
some with a similar voice
type who speaks english,
you know what I mean?
- What is it about, you also did this in
"Devilman Crybaby" as
well, where Rio's English
was just so awkward.
- Stop doing this shit,
stop doing this.
- And yet somehow they
can't get, I made this joke
on Twitter, but I think it was the second
to last episode when they were in Russia.
- [Connor] Yeah
- Yeah.
- And they got those like three nurses
who could speak perfect
Russian and yet they can't get
a single English speaking voice actor.
- The Russian was flawless.
- I was like, why?
How is it so hard?
- Cause in the dub, how do they deal
with the bilingual ness?
- They, they didn't really,
the boy just always spoke
English, so that's why...
- Did they mentioned it at
all that he could speak both?
- No, I mean like they kind of did,
- I wanted them to just be like,
oh, I wanna meet my (in foreign language).
(laughs)
- Is it like a huge plot point
'cause then later on when they
all like the barrage comes
with the Japanese only.
- Oh, the Japanese KKK.
(laughs)
- Okay, the whole you know,
the, the dynamics of that boat,
just the engineering
standards were all horrific.
How did that boat which
couldn't handle waves,
like waves could just come on.
- It literally burst into
flames, for no reason.
- Oh my God, sorry.
I just got, yeah, it was engineering.
- The more we discussing this
the more I'm regretting giving it a seven.
- The emotions it gave me we're a 10.
- Yeah.
- Like, like let's, let's not
forget that they also added
a woman who could speak to the dead
that was just never explained.
- What was up with that,
what was up with that.
Why did they show us the sex scene?
- Like there was several
points in the cult arc.
- Why did they show her sex scene?
I don't need to see that shit.
- There was two points
I bust out laughing.
One, one was the kid dying
and the second one was
like the fucking Mexican standoff,
where she's just brings a samurai sword.
- I was like is this "Kill Bill",
is this a "Kill Bill" scene.
- That was such a Quentin
Tarantino scene where it's like
there's a guy with a bag
full of gold bars and a gun,
and she just rocks off
with a samurai sword
and the guides walks
up the stairs is like.
- And I'm just like, what am I watching,
I thought I was watching
like a disaster movie
and it's turned into "Kill Bill".
I couldn't stop taking sick,
I couldn't stop laughing at that point.
- What did you guys think
of the last episode?
- It was a really...
- I really fucking hated
the last episode.
- Yeah, the last, the last episode
just kind of dragged out
for a little bit too long.
- The last episode was,
remember when the Olympics
was meant to happen right now.
(laughs)
This is, this is awkward.
- Don't forget the
Paralympics just got too,
just gotta make sure.
- I'm sure it would have hit harder
because the Olympics would
be happening right now.
- Yeah.
- If this was released
right now, I'd be like
oh, that's, that's a pro
game of move there Yuasa.
So I, I see, I see you
but now, but now that the
Olympics isn't happening.
It was just one giant ad for the Olympics.
- Oh no, it was.
- I didn't wanna say that
but like, it definitely
like felt little, little ad like.
Look how amazing the
Olympics are and it's like.
- Yeah, we we know.
- Yeah.
- We know how good the Olympics are
or how good it should have been.
- Because I didn't like maybe I, it was
I wasn't paying attention to this
but I saw a lot of
people commenting saying
that the show is like
very political at times
and I was thinking like, I don't know
if it was that political people
trying to put that on it.
Like I didn't get that.
Did you get that vibe?
- No, not really.
Maybe they we're talking
about the rap scene?
- Maybe.
- Which I liked.
- I liked the rap scene.
- I like the rap scene.
- That was a, this doesn't,
this is a really random scene
but I'm all for it.
- It was a good scene,
it was random though.
I was like, I don't know what this is
but we can keep doing it.
- But it's also Yuasa move where, you know
he was just like, okay, I
really want to tell people
how much I love Japan,
but how much Japan sucks
but not make a super political.
- Yeah.
- Freestyle rap, baby let's do it.
(laughs)
- So originally was the rap in Japanese
and the Japanese stuff?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like, I didn't notice because,
at that point I was just
purely watching the English dub
and it was all in English
and it was really,
really done well so I
didn't know if it was a case
where they just like had that
one specific scene in English,
but not like I really enjoyed that.
I really enjoyed the last two episodes
not the last two episodes,
like episode nine
and the one before that.
- Yeah, those are two
really strong episodes.
- Yeah, they had like, like I said
I wasn't invested in the
characters at that point
which was really weird
because there were some scenes that like,
I felt something, even
though I had zero investment
in the story and the characters
but just because of like the
sheer brilliance of some,
some of the ways these scenes
were directed, I was like,
man, I'm, I'm feeling something
even though I really
shouldn't be right now.
- Yeah.
- Did the mom have to die?
- Like I was thinking, like
I was like, did she have to
enter life here for this?
Cause they kind of went
like, I don't know.
They probably went
further, but there was like
one minute on the boat,
oop, it's out of fuel.
- I think it was implied
though that, because her
like device hadn't run out of battery,
that she was officially going to die.
- But didn't shift then,
like a solar panel.
- No, no, because like that
thing hadn't become busted.
So the implication was that
she was going to die anyway.
- Oh, I didn't pick that
up 'cause I thought,
is she just killing herself
for like the (murmurs) here.
Like, she's drowning of like...
- I mean at this point.
- She's like aI have to feel in my
one death per episode quota.
- Yeah, at this point it was just,
they were just killing characters off.
- That's what it felt like.
It felt like they were like
every character was going to die now
and we were just having to sit through it.
Like, it didn't feel like it was needed.
- Yeah.
- And the one character
that should have died
a million years ago,
which is the cripple doctor, survived.
- How? Somehow, I don't know how.
- No, like, yeah that was
my biggest problem with it
because it wasn't the fact
that people were dying.
It was the fact that you just knew
that we're gonna die.
Like it was just, okay
here's the scene where
this person's gonna die.
You know, there's no tension or anything.
You're just, okay, well
they're going to die
and they're dead and
everyone's moving on now.
- And it's sad and you should be sad
and Japan sinking.
- Yeah, so like...
- But YouTuber good.
- Yeah, YouTuber good.
(laughs)
- No, it's really weird though
because I was having this conversation
with Garnt earlier though.
I think we can, we can end
the spoiler discussion now.
- No more spoilers.
- Unless, unless there's anything else
you guys want to discuss
about the series specifically.
- Why pro games did he become (murmurs)
(laughs)
And totally unrealistic,
and he's not a little shit.
I mean she kind of was there
actually, maybe he was,
maybe he was a league player that dies,
why are you (laughs).
Why are you, sorry, okay.
- No, but so yeah, it
was, it was really weird
because even though it was
like, I would give like a four
or five hours at the end of the day,
I still ended having like good
time watching your Netflix.
I don't know, I don't know why.
- I couldn't look away, like it was great.
- I don't why we're it's, I find it so
easy to watch anime on Netflix,
as opposed to watching anime
on like any other platform.
- I've been saying this since early 2018
ever since "Devilman Crybaby" and other,
it as around the time when
Netflix had just started
to get their hands on a
lot of anime, IPS that
with at least with stuff
that comes out on Netflix,
you know Castlevania did it really well.
- Oh, Castlevania was good.
- I think, I think the reason
why Netflix can kill it
so hard with animates
because they know that
most enemy view is including
probably all three of us,
we'd like to watch shows
just in one big chunk.
- Oh, my God Castlevania so fucking...
- Yeah, Castlevania is
fucking amazing, right.
And I think what it is is that because
whenever they really
something new, they just go,
"We know you can't wait an entire week
so we're just gonna give you
the whole thing all in one go."
And it's perfect because
Netflix is designed to binged.
- Yes to be binged.
- Right?
- Yeah, it also feels like
there's no seasonal pressure
as well if there's just
one big show that drops,
go and watch it right now.
- It's not, it's not under
any kind of like scheduling.
- No, it's not sometimes.
- Cause I've had plenty of shows where
I wanna binge them and I wait
like they're on Crunchy Roll
or Funimation or whatever platform.
And I'm like, okay, I'm
going to wait for this,
for this to be over and
then I'm gonna binge it
and then it's over, and
then I don't binge it
and I just don't watch it.
- Yeah, because by the time
it ends there's another whole
new batch that you're interested in, now.
So you never have time to go back to it.
- Yeah, and then I've watched so many
like mediocre anime on Netflix.
I have no idea why, but like...
- You can download it,
it's super easy, like
I remember watching, I think
"B: The Beginning" as well.
I was like severely disappointed
in how that turned out but I watched it,
I watched it all in one night and I still,
there are still many shows
on every other platform
that I just still have not watched
and I'm just like, oh
my plan to watch this.
So yeah I don't know
what it is about watching
shows on Netflix, it's just makes it so...
- It's just painless, like
it's so easy to watch.
Like make it way too easy for you to
enjoy it the way you wanna enjoy it.
Yeah, they just know how
the viewing habits of
people of our demographic.
- And the app works so well on your phone.
So it's easy to just chuck that shit
on the Chrome cast, or download
in the phone, like, you know
saves where you want, it's just so good.
- We're not sponsored by Netflix
but just letting you now.
- But if they wanna hit us up.
(laughs)
- Good yeah.
- Okay, how'd you feel about
the skip opening button though?
- I love the skip opening button.
I like the option.
- I like, I like having the option.
- Yeah, but like, but I
don't like how the default
is that they skip it.
- It's default though, it's default.
- Yeah, I don't like how the
default is skipping because...
- Wait they don't skip it straight away.
- Yeah, they do.
- The first time you watch
it, you don't have the option.
Well, you do have the option to skip it
but plays it for you, it's masculine
but every time after that then...
- They just assume that
you're going to skip it.
Which sucks because when I was watching,
"Beastars" on Netflix, I was like
I don't want to skip this comedy...
- "Beastars" you watch, because yeah
you don't have to do it.
- [Joey] So I had to keep going.
- You have to touch it Garnt,
it's there in case you
don't want it. (laughs)
It's not like, touch me, touch me, Garnt.
- Speaking of Masaaki Yuasa though like,
how much Yuasa stuff have
you guys watched in the past?
- I've watched most of this
stuff except for probably Kyber.
- "Devilman" is that his?
- Yeah, that's the one.
- Yeah, "Devilman" is his.
- What else has he done?
- Oh, "Eizouken" as well.
It's it's fun, it's funny
that's how I still haven't
watched "Eizouken" even though I've,
I've watched "Japan Sinks"
which I feel like is gonna be worse
and "Eizouken" and "Eizouken"
is been out for a while.
- Is that "Eizouken" the
"Ping Pong The Animation"?
- [Connor] Oh, I love
"Ping Pong The Animation".
- He's done "Kyber".
- "Mindgame".
- "Mindgame", he's done
"Kick-heart" as well
which was the kick start to one.
- He's done a lot of indie films as well.
Yeah, "Your Wave".
- Oh, I haven't seen, I
haven't seen "Ride Your Wave".
- I still haven't seen that.
I really wanna watch that.
It's about the, it's like a
girlfriend, boyfriend dies,
they both love the ocean and then
boyfriend reincarnates as a wave.
(laughs)
- That's the only way
to describe it, right.
That's the easiest way to describe it.
- Sounds like a Hentai.
- Boyfriend resurrects as
a water beast essentially.
- 'Cause I think my favorite
Yuasa work will like
is at the moment
"Ping-Pong" the animation.
- [Connor] Oh, my God.
- That's, it hit me on like
a really fucking deep level.
- It hit different.
- I really want to stop saying that
'cause like every time we're on is like,
oh, this show just hits the different.
- It do be hitting different.
I guess 'cause it sounds
like relatable in some way.
Like you've probably been good
at something without trying
and you've also probably not
been good at something...
- We had a lot of comments last week.
That was, yeah Connor's
chest stories, basically
"Ping Pong The Animation" just with chess.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean,
but the way you just portrayed,
because to me it's not a
sports anime, you know, it's,
to me "Ping Pong The
Animation" is a life anime
that happens to follow characters around
one single one, single sports.
Cause it's, it's such a good
metaphor for life in general.
When it, when it comes to
the discussion of talent
versus hard work and just basically
how crushingly depressing
life can be sometimes.
- Life isn't fair.
- Yeah, life, life is not fair.
- And no one's entitled to
anything, unfortunately.
- I mean, that's the whole
reason why I fucking loved
"March Comes in Like a Lion"
'cause that's essentially the exact scene.
- Haven't seen that yet,
I really wanna see that.
- It's not a show that show you.
You'll get into (in foreign
language) after watching it
but it much like "Ping
Pong The Animation",
it's just a story about how,
it doesn't matter how
good you are at something.
You're still gonna be depressed as fuck
- That's the reason I've
been putting it off,
I'm like, I don't want to be depressed.
- It gets pretty upsetting.
- I know it does,
I know it does everyone who's watched it,
is like, yeah I loved
it, I was just ruined.
- It's so good though.
- Do you think "Japan
Sinks" is his worst work
that you've seen so far then?
- Out of like the three I've
seen, yeah, it's probably.
- I mean I haven't seen everything,
Masaaki Yuasa has to offer.
- Yeah.
- I've seen a lot, but
I I'd probably say it's,
yeah, it's probably his weakness.
- I think definitely for
me it was weakest and...
- Literally just remove the cult.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's good.
- So many problems will
be solved if he just
had removed the cult episode.
- Yeah, I wanna say not
every problem would be solved
but a lot of it, it would
be like a lot better
'Cause they still had problems with
how the characters were written.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And how the story played out,
but removing, removing the middle arch
would have made it like an
easy seven to eight or 10.
- Yeah.
- Because there were still, like I said,
there was still some amazing scenes.
- Oh yes, there was some
plenty of amazing scenes.
- And he was like (murmurs)
if I was actually invested,
I would think that the show had some
pretty amazing moments in it,
because I feel like
just it got bogged down
by stories so much.
- Yeah.
- Whereas his other works, I feel it was,
it was a like a nice combination between
this Yuasa style of
directing because he has a,
I don't know some of his scenes the way,
the way he portrays and directs,
especially like the emotional scenes
they just, they can hit really hard
and I don't know what he does.
- You're so close to saying that.
- [Joey] Shut the fuck up.
- I said it in my head.
I was like, I'll fall for it.
- It like hits the source for a different.
- Yeah, I agree I
definitely think that Yuasa
regardless of how strange it is
that the way that he portrays you know,
character designs and
just movement in general.
- [Garnt] And just animation.
- Okay, I'm one of those enemy viewers
who does not care who the director is
or any of that stuff.
I just watch the show and
that's how I watch an anime.
I do that with everything.
So, I mean, I could tell
it was from the same guy
who did "Devilman" within like 10 seconds.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Just tell, that's how.
- Because Yuasa's films and series
have this really weird thing where
sometimes you look at a character design
and you think, oh wow.
- They're ugly as fuck.
- That looks pretty cool
and then the next scene, it looks
like it's written by like
the intern, you know.
- It changes, I think there
was like a few frames in it
where it was like the
characters just talking
and it was like, bro, like pain.
(laughs)
I was like, what?
- You can take a screenshot of that
and just be...
- I will say out of like all his works.
I feel like "Japan
Sinks" was his most like
normal looking work in
terms of visual style.
- Big unquotes for.
- No, no you know you like
you compare "Ping-Pong"
the animation and then you
go to "Devilman Crybaby"
and then "Japan Sinks".
I would, I would say
he's progressively gotten
in terms of his big series.
- Yeah.
- More, more like normal.
- "Ping Pong" is one ugly looking show
but in great way.
- In a great way.
- Like he had a very unique art style
and some of the scenes were like
they had a very unique
animation style and some,
I would still say sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't work so well
but it was definitely a very Yuasa style.
- At least you know it's him.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- How many fucking of
those generic (murmurs)
are you like, are these all animated
by the same fucking people.
They all look the same, I can't tell.
- You ask any (murmurs)
and they'll probably know.
It's like this was directed by...
- I don't, I don't care.
Like I just, I see an ECI protagonists now
and it's literally a
carbon copy of Kirito.
I remember doing like a copy and paste of
seven different like ECI, protagonists
and they all look exactly the same.
It was all that generic.
- Probably because they roll A1.
- It's the exact same art style,
the exact same animation all the time
and it's like, it's such a breath
of fresh air to even
get anything different.
- Oh, no definitely.
- That's what I love about
Masaaki Yuasa, because he's just so weird
that he's just instantly
recognizable, especially,
you know "Japan Sinks", as you were saying
even though it looks the most normal
probably to the general
anime viewing audience
they will look at those
characters and be like,
oh that looks fucking weird.
But then you go back to
Masaaki Yuasa's catalog.
You watch something like "Kyber"?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like that thing that
doesn't even look like anime.
- Yeah.
- That thing looks like, you know
some kind of like Disney demo
that it was locked away in
the Disney vault for a while.
- But let me say this
about "Jojo" as well,
I like the art styles are weird,
I can't get into that, like you'll know.
(laughs)
You'll appreciate.
- It's an acquired taste.
- Once you, once you acquire that taste
there is never going back.
- Taste acquired.
(laughs)
I like "Jojo" now.
- I was gonna say I completely
forgot about the one show
and you're also getting
one show when we're talking
about Masaaki Yuasa, "Tatami Galaxy".
"Tatami Galaxy" was fucking...
Like you watched, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's fucking amazing.
- It's "Monogatari" but on crack.
- It is "Monogatari"...
- Like this, this will test
your reading ability to the max.
- The monologue is so fast,
that Japanese people
struggle to keep up with it,
they are like hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on, pause, pause, pause.
What the fuck did he just say, go back.
Yeah, it's the, I've
never heard of monologue
and just talking scenes that
go by so goddamn quickly.
- Yeah.
- It is, it is "Monogatari"
on crack essentially.
It's basically like if
you take "Monogatari"
but try to speed run
the dialogue and that's,
that's an episode of "Tatami Galaxy"
but it's fucking great.
- Yeah.
- And that's on top of the fucking crazy
Masaaki Yuasa visual,
where it's just like, I don't know if this
is like a dream scape
or if it's just weird.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but it's great, it's fantastic.
- One thing I wanted to,
one thing that we kind of
like glossed over in terms
of "Japan Sinks", I wanna talk
about though, is the music.
I thought the music was fantastic.
I thought it was phenomenal
and I think that's definitely
some of it made some it,
it was what helped make
some of the scenes for me.
- Yeah.
- That main track,
I think it played most
of the first episode
when the main character was running back
to a family that kind of
slow piano, I think so.
I'd love that track because
it's really positive sounding
and get putting it next
to the absolutely devastating visuals.
It's just become such a creepy song,
where it's like, oh everything
and everyone is dead.
- 'Cause like, I think like what sold me
on the first two episodes
was just seeing some
of these like horrific
scenes, horrific landscapes
and hearing this beautiful piano track
that just gave this like
juxtaposition that just like
it was really unnerving but
beautiful at the same time.
Like I, the way I described
it to Sydney was it felt
like I was watching some,
something that was horrifically beautiful.
- Yeah.
- And I, that was...
- Was like a beautiful destruction.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly
and I don't know who the composer was.
It sounded very similar to
"Devilman Crybaby" soundtrack
in some scenes as well.
I don't know if it's the same composer.
I probably should have done my research
before talking about "Japan
Sinks" on this podcast.
- I mean I'm sure, it
was done by Science SARU.
who did you know, "Devilman Crybaby".
So I assume it's the same
guy, but I don't know.
I'm sure someone in the comments
can tell us about that but.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love that piano track because
I don't know, I'm not gonna
lie the first time I heard it.
It kind of reminded me of
the "Minecraft" soundtrack,
a little bit.
(laughs)
I was like if this play
during "Minecraft",
I would not be phased in any way.
Can someone in the subreddit
take that piece of music
and put it over "Minecraft", let's play
and see if you can spot it.
- It's like, God, this
was such horrific beauty.
The juxtaposition was
amazing, Garnt "Minecraft".
- He says like "Minecraft"
but that's what I, I was like "Minecraft"
- I don't know if I'm just dumb
but I cannot remember any of the music.
- Really can't?
- No, I will sing them when sitting there.
- Yeah, we all did.
- Did you watch in one sitting?
- Yeah.
- Okay, I don't remember.
- We just have a bigger brain.
(laughs)
- Clearly, I think I was preoccupied.
How do they get a tank?
- Okay, a question to you then.
what kind of OSTs do you remember,
what sticks out for you then?
- Fuck.
(laughs)
Anything where like the music
is like a huge selling point, I guess.
- What, what do you mean?
- Oh, I mean, I don't want to be that guy
but like the one that sticks
out immediately is like,
do you remember "Cowboy Bebop",
like the super jazzy thing,
like but I wouldn't
listen to jazz on its own.
I'm like something like this
just sounds like a mess.
- I mean I've come to understand
that when it comes to music
you're a little bit brain dead,
because you don't, you
don't really listen to
because you know, Garnt and I
can have a conversation of,
oh, this band is awesome
or this artist is awesome.
And yet I remember I asked Connor once.
I was like, well, who's
your favorite band?
And he was just like I don't
really have one, I'm like.
- I like, I like Daft Punk you know why,
'cause it's just noise, most of the time.
Like, I, I hate like I
never listen to lyrics.
Like I love like listen to,
like, I think I listened
to like pumped up kicks
like a thousand times.
So someone was like, it's
about school shooting and
I actually listened to it.
They are like, oh yeah yes it is, yeah.
I don't know if I'm just like,
I don't know what's wrong with me.
- You are monkey brain?
It's a monkey brain coming back, man.
- I have like half monkey
brain, half giant brain
depending on like what a...
- Do you have a single composer?
- Kevin Penkin.
- I was about to say
aside from Kevin Penkin
'cause he's our fucking mate.
He's like, he's, he's
not composing our minds.
He's just some better...
- Do you know what he composed
of the "Made in Abyss"?
- Yeah, he did...
- And all of them "Tower of God"?
- "Shield Hero".
- Okay.
- Shield hero is pretty,
the boys is not completely
branded, that's good.
- I guess, because I focus more on the
voice acting than anything
and that's like taking up all the
noise input I can take, right.
Like I don't really give
a shit about the music.
To me, the music is just like.
- Does the music not enhance
your viewing experience?
- The music to me is so fucking important.
- Yeah.
- No, not really.
- Like, if, if there's a
series with a good soundtrack
I'm still gonna remember that soundtrack.
- I absolutely agree.
- To this day, like I will
never forget "Guilty Crown"
despite how shit "Guilty
Crown" turned into.
- Sawano fucking killed
it with that sound.
That is a fucking thing.
- There some songs that
like will invoke an emotion
in me from like, if they've
been a soundtrack bus.
As far as it goes, it's like no.
- Have you ever listened
to a Sawano soundtrack
and just gotten pumped up?
- No, no.
- [Joey] Not at all?
- Like maybe at the gym
like I'll put anime
soundtrack to get hyped to
and maybe, you know, a song,
a song will come on.
- But say for example, "Promare".
- Yeah.
- You fucking love that movie, right.
- It was a great movie.
- Do you remember the soundtrack?
- No.
- How?
- What how, how is it that
the most in your face composer
that has ever existed
in anime, Connor's like,
"No.", no impression.
- If you were like, if you
were like, if you were like,
describe a song to me
from, from happy life...
no fucking idea, no clue.
- If you watch "Promare",
you watch "Attack on Titan"
what other, what other sound.
- Yeah, "Attack on
Titan" the one that goes,
I remember wanting from "Attack on Titan",
I don't know what...
- "Kill to Kill", you
remember "Kill to Kill"?
- Yeah, "Kill to Kill".
- That's all, Sawano, that's all, Sawano.
- Yeah, I remember like individual songs
but if you ask me to like describe them
or what I like about them, I'd be like
but like crayon colors to me.
Like I don't know, for all
I care you could put like
fucking Kevin MaCleod
music, whatever he's called.
- Kevin MaCleod?
- MaCleod, that's what is called.
Like if you put Kevin MaCleod background.
- The creative...composer.
(upbeat music)
(laughs)
You can put those fucking
songs, I don't give a fuck.
- To be fair, some of the
best shows I've listened to
have sounded like some
Kevin MaCleod music.
- Oh, no there's like,
there's definitely been
some generic sounding soundtracks that.
- Yeah.
- But they're normally like
for generic shows, right
but I don't know a soundtrack
can easily sell me a series.
- I wish I could give
a fuck, I don't know.
It's with music as well, I love Daft Punk.
I was just like, wow.
The, the noise sounds nice.
Like I like the noise,
you know what I mean?
Is that weird?
(laughs)
- Yes, it is weird.
- Am I weird?
- It is very weird.
- I know I think you just
basically described music in,
in the most like I think bare
bones monkey brains terms.
- It is a bunch of noises put together.
- Think I actually am like
a caveman when it comes
to music, I'm like, ooh, beeps
and boops are very pleasing.
- Music goes, boop.
- Yeah, yeah music goes boop.
- I mean that's a huge
reason why when it comes
to soundtracks that's a huge
reason why I love anything
made by Key Studios, right
because Maeda Jun is a
fucking amazing composer
and he's like just subtle piano tracks
or any of the openings
and everything's just
it builds on the scene so fucking nicely
and it adds like a whole, like.
- Totally.
- At least to me, I don't know.
Maybe I'm the only one
but I could just listen to say any track
from "Clannad" or "Air"
or "Little busters".
Yeah, and it could be a specific song
that can evoke a specific scene
and I could easily shed a tear
just from listening to it.
- Like his work is basically
if you wanna hit the emotional G-spot.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like you, you hear it and
you're like, oh, oh shit no.
- How does a single piano put
this much emotion behind it.
I have no fucking idea.
- I feel like the Mike Wazowski meme where
he's just standing there, right.
Just listening to this conversation.
He goes...I don't know.
- You are the first
person to ever describe
Daft Punk as noise.
- It's like.
- I'm just saying.
- Pleasant noise is the way I like it.
- Pleasant, you mean music?
- "Interstellar Three",
whatever it's called.
What is it, Interstellar?
- "5555"
- "5555" that's great.
- Yeah, I love that.
- It's great I love that.
(laughs)
- Has a track never evoked
emotions from you though?
- Have you never listened too...
- Like actual, actual emotion?
- Okay, what's your
favorite Daft Punk track?
- Oh, that's hard.
I have to run. I really
like "Face to Face".
- Okay, why is it your favorite track?
- Oh, my God.
- Is it because it evokes an emotion or?
- You can see in his face
he's never thought about this,
this deeply before.
- What is this, my favorite song.
- No, I like all the sampling in it
and it gets like crazy how
creative they were sampling.
- Right, so you're looking at them.
So is there like a think
about the one Daft Punk song,
it doesn't have to be Daft Punk,
just think about the
one song that has evoked
like any kind of emotion in you.
What song would that be and
what emotion would that be?
- Yeah, I don't think there is.
I think there was a song
that evoked emotions in me.
Is that, right?
What does it mean, what does
that mean about me as a person?
- I'm talking to a
fucking brick wall here.
(laughs)
- It's like trying to explain to, you know
Peppa the android, what music is,
it's just like, it says not compute.
- I feel like I'm alien right now.
- What is emotion?
- What is culture,
what is this?
- I don't know, I guess like for me,
maybe that's why like I focus
or I feel like I'm really
strong in being able to
really break down voice acting
and shares and really like get into it
but I think that's cause I'm
completely fucking ignoring.
- What like brings emotions to you?
- The story and the
characters and performances.
- Okay, but does not,
but does voice acting not
give you emotion?
- Yeah, the voice acting does.
- Okay, so how come music can't do that?
- I don't know, I guess I
can't like, I don't know.
It doesn't connect, I don't know.
- Do you know a medium
where you can feel emotion
just by a story and characters?
- Books.
- Books, I wish we was...
- But I'm like,
I don't wanna read the book.
I want someone to read it for me.
The music for me is something
that like ties it together
and it's something that if
it's done well, I don't notice
and if it's done badly, I will notice.
- Okay, no I agree with that.
- Which is the way I think
that most people view like voice acting.
- No, no I agree with how,
if music is done well,
if it's done so well
then sometimes you can't notice it but,
but then there's a level.
- Cause I don't, I don't look out for it.
Like I don't seek that.
- No, no when I say, when I say good
I mean like just like satisfactory.
Like satisfactory music
you don't notice it
but you will definitely hear
when a soundtrack is really funny.
- What is attracted
that using amazing ways.
I'll notice that track and I'll like,
have like a little...
- Right, but does that
not give you emotion or?
- Like you've definitely heard the Sawano?
- Yeah, and I'm like,
yeah, I get a little hype,
just about it.
Unlike, I'm excited from this one
and I, (laughs)
go protagonist.
- Have you ever watched like, okay.
My favorite soundtrack of all time
is probably (murmurs).
- I remember enjoying that show a lot.
- So good.
- I remember the music was
sad. I don't know about...
- Oh, this hurts me so a lot.
The music was sad, yes.
- The music was sad,
is like saying peppers are hot.
- The way I see it like when you,
when you talk about music to me
you need to filter it through like
the YouTube audio, library tags
Like genre and mood, that's the only thing
I understand about music.
Tell me the genre of music
and the mood it wants.
- Okay, you watched (murmurs)?
- Yeah, I loved it.
- Okay, it had the whole Icelandic
like kind of post rock drums...
- The, the motorbike scene where they're
on like the motor and
it's nothing but just no,
no dialogue, it's just
them riding on a motorbike
with beautiful visual and beautiful music.
- Yeah.
- Do you remember that scene?
- No.
I remember them being terrorists.
- Oh, this is I'm feeling
so fucking frustrated now.
Oh, my God.
- I just remember them
being like terrorists, right
and it was fun anime.
- You remember them being terrorists.
(laughs)
- I remember them blowing up shit.
- That's like saying at "Attack on Titan",
I remember the big Titans.
There's time, dude.
- Yeah... dude I remember
enjoying that show
but like when I finished it's gone.
- Okay, then let's steer
away, let's go down.
Let's go down to the most
like rudimentary level here.
Let's let's go to, okay.
What is your favorite anime opening?
- Oh, that's good.
I really liked the (murmurs).
- Why?
- It's hype as fuck.
- Okay, but what makes it,
like, like what emotions do
you feel when listening to it,
is it excitement?
Is it like?
- Okay, so how come you can
put emotion into that song but.
- What, what makes, what
makes that memorable?
- Yeah, what makes that memorable?
- Yeah, the opening part is pretty hype.
You know, the...
- That's just a meme.
- I love it though, it's good.
What else do I like?
I mean, the "Jojo", the "Jojo"
opening is hype as fuck.
- Which one?
(murmurs).
- Oh, no, no Jawani Steve
- Why does that?
- Why do you, why do
you like Jawani Steve?
- When did that stand up?
- As I said, I think I tweeted it.
I was like, it's the "Bohemian Rhapsody".
- What does that mean?
- Cause there's so much going on.
It's like a five minute
song and it's just like so
many things happening and I'm
like, wow, this is amazing.
(laughs)
- I don't know if it's the
coffee or this conversation
but I'm actually getting a headache.
I'm getting like a brain
aneurism right now.
- I imagine the viewers at home were like
what is wrong with this kid?
- I'm like dying inside
just listening to this.
How have I never had this
conversation with you before?
- I guess cause every
time you bring a music,
I think I just go like, yeah okay.
- If we went to school together you'd be
that one kid who would
wear a cocoa bean T-shirt
not knowing who Navon was,
you know what I mean. (laughs)
- And be like be like,
yeah, I like his face.
- Yeah, I like that team spirit song.
- Yeah, team spirit, what is, it?
Looks like team spirit...
So, okay what else do you value
anything else in the anime,
aside from like stories
and characters then.
- I mean the visuals are
really important, right.
Like, I feel that it's like,
it's not so much that I
don't appreciate music.
It's again, like I said,
like, if it's done well
it blends in and I don't really
pay much attention to it.
- Okay, but you remember the
"Cowboy Bebop" sound track?
- Yeah.
- Okay, why do you remember that?
- I remember it went like really
well with all the carrier.
Like what, all the movements
in that show like blended so well music
and I remember it like
made them both stand
out more than anything at the
time when I was watching it.
Because the carrier...
- So your argument is that because
the feeling of the soundtrack is...
- Is not an argument.
- Is so completely.
- I'm just saying, like I'm not
trying to argue or anything.
I'm just saying that's
what I remember is cause...
- No, no because, because you kind of
because your logic, from
what I'm understanding
your logic is that I don't
think about this too much.
- Yeah, you're logic
is that "Cowboy Bepop"
soundtrack you remember,
because the feeling and vibe you got
from the musical so different
to the visuals, right?
- No, no, because I can't put the visuals
without the music there.
- Okay, so how come you
don't remember (murmurs)?
- I don't know.
- Because it does the exact same thing.
- I remember like, maybe like
two scenes from (murmurs), literally.
- And do they involve any music?
- No, I remember seeing
the building explode.
- I was about to say, I was about to say.
The only scene you remember.
- And I remember someone getting sniped
(laughs)
and I remember being sad by the snipped.
- I was expecting to say
that you were very impressed
with the nose...
- Who this man's aim in a helicopter,
very impressed you know,
must have some very...
All right, like, when I
watch a show that was good
but not like, life-changing
it kind of just goes in the back
of my head and I remember like...
- Apparently if you
watch life-changing shows
you don't remember the music anyway.
So it's like.
- I remember "Bokurano" theme.
I remember a book around a theme.
- Everyone knows that song.
- That's who I remember
from "Bokurano" the music.
- See you don't remember the soundtrack?
- No, not at all.
- I remember the soundtrack
being pretty good to "Bokurano".
- No clue.
- I actually, I don't remember that.
I just remember the opening.
- This man doesn't remember
one single soundtrack,
how dare?
- Because after the last episode or sorry,
a couple of episodes back,
I went and re watched a couple
of episodes of "Bokurano"
just because I haven't
seen it in such a long time
and the sound, I remember the soundtrack.
I was like, wow, this soundtrack
is really fucking good.
- It's like for some reason
I cannot, for the life of me,
remember character names
after the end of the show.
Like I'm just like, it's the blue head one
and he does something.
- It's not even monkey bar this is...
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- I genuinely like, it's so weird
'cause I'll remember so many
things vividly in my life
but when it comes to entertainment
and stuff that I consume
it's like, already goes.
- I mean, I guess that's
good because you probably
just infinite rematch ability, right.
- Yeah, I can rematch shows
on that, getting driven out,
'cause I forget because
I forget half the shit,
that I've seen.
Like what are they re
watched something recently
and I remember being like very impressed.
I'm like, I forgot all, I
re watched "Breaking Bad"
and I was like, I forgot
how all of this shit.
Through seasons one through
five, I don't remember anything.
- I mean, that's a long
show so that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
- That's I don't know,
is that weird I'm sure
that people in the comments
who are the same but like
don't remember any characters,
don't remember the soundtracks.
- I've I've met, I've met someone.
- Why are you watching...
- Yeah.
- I love the experience,
it's like leave me alone.
I get what I get out of it.
- Do you enjoy the experience
but you don't remember after it.
- Do you remember everything
that you consumed?
- I've legitimately never
had this conversation.
Like this, this compensation
is a first to me.
I've never, I've never had to explain
to someone why music is like a good thing.
- [Connor] I know.
- In terms of entertainment.
- I'm not arguing that
it's not a good thing,
I just don't remember it.
- Okay, I am convinced
right that people lie
about like when you have
discussions with them
and you're like, yeah you
remember the soundtrack?
I'm just convinced that, just like, yeah,
yeah, it was totally great.
- I mean like the sound...
- Definitely people would
do that all the time.
- No, but like to say this
not a single soundtrack
from like some of your favorite
series that you remember.
- I can't remember anything.
- But if you hear it, you'll...
- If I hear it I will recognize,
I'll be able to pull out that memory from
the dusty old cabinet.
- Right, but then you'll pull it out
and what you'll pull out a
file that's just as good.
- I'm like nice.
(laughs)
But it's like, okay, it's like,
I can remember voice
performances quite well
but that's because I an active interest in
really learning those
and really studying that.
- So what do you sell makes
a good voice performance then
and is it something that
has to be in English
or does it how can you recognize it
in like Japanese as well?
- Yeah, Japanese too but I think that's
just from watching a
lot of Japanese media.
It's something that you can,
because the way you deliver
a line, anything, right.
The way I vision, the align, there's a
when you deliver a singular line
there's like a visualization to it.
If you imagine the pacing
and the pitch like that,
in my head with a good line,
there's a set way it
should be delivered, right
and that's the way the
director wants it to
and then I imagined like
someone like Quentin Tarantino
has the same idea where it's
like the line is delivered
the way I see it.
And so it's like, I just visualize
in my head the way it should go,
like if you should raise your voice,
how you should raise your pitch
and then what when you
should take it down,
when you should slow it
down, when you start a pause
and it's really
interesting seeing how like
some of the actors will
deliver a certain line
and where they'll choose a...pauses
or how those choose to slow it down.
I think that's really interesting.
- No, I'm just saying like you know,
I haven't done as much voicing as you
but I definitely take a keen
eye to voice acting as well
because I also wanna get better at it.
- Yeah.
- I totally get what you
mean with the cult casting.
- There's a way I wish that like,
I wish I figured out a way
where I could definitively
show people what I mean in
my head about that because
if you put the line on like
an axis of Y on the like X,
you know, would, it would
go like that, right.
It'd be like, you need to pause here.
You need to take a break
here, slow down this word
this words in italics. So
please put emphasis on it
but not too much emphasis, let it be bold.
It's like really loads of
nuances that we don't see
as the audience that
I'm trying to in my head
when I'm listening to something,
I'm imagining how they saw the script.
I'm trying to think back
to what they were thinking.
So like, depending on
what medium we're in now,
like and also ever since I
got way too into voice acting
I see so much ADL and it puts
me the fuck off in films.
When you can hear one line
that's delivered in the room
and one line, whether you did it in post,
it's so grating, when you
hear just like so many sitcoms
do this where they like
have the line done in post.
You don't realize how many
movies have done in post as well.
I know they've done so well.
- Yeah, I've definitely
noticed it recently when.
- It's so grating.
- Yeah, like when you notice it once
you can't stop noticing it, I noticed.
- And that's the problem I have with
watching shows that are
dubbed in languages like,
you know, Italian or whatever or Dutch
normally they're, they'd
have to dub so many shows
where they're just pumping this out
and there's not really much
given to the sound of it
and it sounds like everyone's in a studio.
Every single TV show they're
in no matter where they go
when I hear this Italian
or this Dutch guy speak
it always sounds like they're in a studio
when they're outside,
it's like, what the fuck.
I hate that so much
and that's the reason
why when people are like,
oh, I watch I had a
German friend who watched
"Game of Thrones" in Dutch
or a German, sorry, dubbed
and I was like, why? It sounds
like everyone's in a studio,
they want a battlefield.
- It's exactly, it's
exactly the same as Ty dubs,
when I was talking about sharing Ty dubs
and they just don't know audio mixing.
So it's sort of like making it sound
like they're in the environment they're in
it's always in the same studio
and instead of like mixing in the voices
they just like quiet every other voice
and every other sound, every other sound.
So the voices are just
like 10 times louder
than every sound effect
every time someone talks
and then the sound
effects get louder again.
- Oh, my God.
- It's like the worst
kind of audio mixing.
- That's lazy as fuck.
- Yeah, I know.
- 'Cause I mean, now I'm not sure
if they did it back then,
but now commonly the Japanese
studios will just give basically a track
which is the voice is taken out.
And they are like, "Here's everything,
we've done it all for
you just add the voices."
Normally quite easy, but
yeah in terms of dubbing
or voice performances and anime cartoons,
that's a whole different like.
- I feel like, I feel like
one unsung hero in terms
of like voice acting and
dubbing is the voice director
because I feel like obviously,
you know, actors get a lot
of the credits but I feel.
- They also got all the shit.
- They also got all the shit though
and like the voice director
has so much control
over how good this voice
performance is gonna be.
Cause I've, I've definitely
worked with voice actors
and actresses in my own, a bridge series
where they've they've
done a great fucking job.
- And then I see them voice
in like other projects and.
- [Connor] It's terrible.
- It's bad, it hurts me
'cause I know the potential
that these voice actors
have and I know that's
it's probably just bad voice
direction, you know and,
and a lot of people don't think
about that or don't know
that because they just think,
oh, it's a voice actor,
you know what I mean.
- Yeah, it's a real shame.
- It's difficult because
unless you've been
in an environment where
you've worked with a director
or had someone directing you in any way
it's really hard to understand
the role of a director.
I didn't quite get it until
I'd worked in that space
and it's kind of the person who like
'cause when you're doing it
for yourself and you're acting
you're in your own head
you're your worst enemy
'cause you're like, fuck I
should've done it this way.
'Cause when I recorded for one
of my own videos, 20 takes.
I record for someone else with a director,
one or two takes because
they tell me what they want
and they help me get there
and a lot of people like
there's 10% of voice actors
who can deliver lines
amazingly without a director.
But then there's like
50% who need a director
and there's like 30, 40% let's be honest,
they're never gonna get any where with it.
But it's hard to say that but
it's one of those things where
you do need like a good
ear somewhat skill.
- It's a skill, absolutely.
- It's definitely a skill
'cause I, I personally
think I'm a much better
voice director than I am a voice actor.
Even though I've done both.
I tried to like insert
my own voice as little
as possible whenever I'm doing kind
of any kind of voice work
that I've done before
but I really enjoyed
directing because it's,
it's definitely a unique skill
'cause I've seen how
other people direct their
their work as well and it's
everyone has a different style.
Some are just not effective at all.
Some, some, voice
directors, you know, they
they have no idea what
they want, you know.
And it's just on the voice actor to save,
to save the performance somehow,
even though the director
has no idea what they wants.
Do you ever get that moment though,
when you're directing someone and you,
they've not delivered the line
exactly the way you want it
and so you have to explain it to them
and you get to the third point, the third
it's the third time, the
third time you've tried
and they still haven't done
it the way you wanted to.
Do you, do you continue?
Like do, do, do you continue
trying to explain it to them
or do you just go with one of the takes?
- Normally I will do,
I would try my best to explain it to them.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Worst case scenario, I'll do a line read
which a line read is you
don't normally do it.
It's kind of, it's not unprofessional
but it wastes a lot of time
which is where the director
will deliver the line and I'll be like,
just copy what I just did.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And that's what I'll do
on the worst case scenario
and if they can't do that,
then it's like, fuck.
This is going to be bad.
Like if they, if they can't
hear one, like what I just did
and then they can't replicate it
that means that they have
no idea what I just did.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- In my head I'm like, okay.
They don't even see what I did,
they don't know what they are doing.
- Yeah, it's the worst beginning
in the world, isn't it?
- It's pretty awful.
- Today video is sponsored by Xenon Zod
is a unique AI based animated card game
for the mobile that's just
been recently released.
- So do you guys know what
the AI card game entitled?
- I have no idea what an AI card is.
- So basically the AI card game,
so in the game you get an AI
buddy that you can choose from
and the choice of the AI buddy
I think there's 16 different AI characters
that you can choose from
and it's based off of this interview
that you do at the beginning of the game
that dictates your personality.
You pick the AI that best
suits your personality
but basically you have an
AI buddy that plays along
and helps you strategize to play Xenon Zod
which is this card game
and the AI buddy like
gives you legitimate advice
on the games, like how
you can beat the game
and like different strategies
and you don't have to
follow the AI but you know,
a lot of the AI's are acute goals
and sometimes they're just
like really cool characters
and you're like, okay, you
know what you're, you're an AI.
- I'll listen to you.
- I'll listen to you, I'll listen to you.
- So as I understand it,
there's also 500 different cards
with seven different categories
and I've also seen a few clips of the game
and the visuals look pretty damn
impressive for a mobile game.
- [Joey] So the actual game
play involves three phases.
You have the monument
phase, the flash phase
and the main phase and the
unique feature about Xenon Zod
is the modern movement
system where you can move
summoned minions to and
from mana in kind of
a really interesting recycling mechanism.
- So as you play against an
AI opponent, you can easily
take breaks whenever you want
but you can also play against PVP as well.
- So if you download the game right now
then you can actually get your
hands on 240 of the 500 cards
available in the game,
just off of ongoing events
and if you use the hashtags and are ACI
on Facebook and Twitter,
you can use that to connect
with other players in the
game or to just battle
and flex your hot AI...
- So if that sounds
interesting to you go down
to the description down
below and download Xenon Zod
today and you could get up to 240
of the exclusive 500 cards.
- Thank you to Xenon Zod for
sponsoring today's episode
and back to the video.
- I did a video series
where I like fixed games,
Hentai anime I redid all
the, the voice acting
from the ground up and
the only rule was that
I wasn't allowed to change.
I was, I was not change
anything about the voice acting.
The whole point of that was to like,
prove to the viewers that like,
listen, you could you can
fix the bad voice acting
but more often than not it's
not the bad voice acting
that is terrible about this
series or thing that you watch.
Like it's normally just cause like
everything else is terrible.
- Yeah.
- And the one thing that
stands out is this dude
who's delivering a line, like.
- Yeah.
- But that's normally as a
result of everything else being
'cause voice actors are the
last priority for most things.
Because then normally the
thing that you do at the end,
at some games and stuff like
games are normally the worst,
worst culprit of terrible voice acting.
Especially Japanese
games that get translated
into English normally have God
fucking awful voice acting.
- Oh, definitely.
- Yeah, A lot of those
games as well just have
absolutely horrible localization.
Just the dialogue, clearly the
person who was translating it
does not have the firmest
grasp of both languages.
- Yeah, and 'cause normally
they're not given like
an amazing budget to do it.
These games are long.
- They get pretty underpaid,
unfortunately, yeah.
So they're just like, whatever
I'll just do the bare minimum
run it through Google
translate if need be.
You know, fuck it no one's
gonna notice the voice
actors are shit anyway who cares.
- The Japanese wording with
like, (in foreign language),
you know, (in foreign language)
means mum in Japanese.
(laughs)
- All according to (murmurs).
- Speaking about voice
actors and voice acting
like the only person who's actually been
in an anime here is you Garnt.
- Yeah, I am.
- Or like an actual Japanese anime.
Like what, what was the
experience like for you then?
- That was really cool because.
- Garnt explain like you
were on "Pop Team Epic"
and what you have to do.
- Yes, so just purely by coincidence,
I got to voice in "Pop Team Epic"
even though all my lines
I did were in English.
It was technically, it
was technically Japanese.
- You were in the sub.
- I'm in the sub.
I know because Funimation
dubbed "Pop Team Epic"
and they didn't use me.
- I don't think they're
allowed to though, legally.
- No they weren't but you know
Funimation you could hit me up bro.
- My DMs were open.
- My DMs were open,
we follow each other on Twitter,
you could have DM me anyway.
So I voiced this it
was this entire episode
that was voiced in English
because "Pop Team Epic" just
no rules, right.
And it was really cool
because I got to voice act
with the guy who voiced
Rio in "Devilman Crybaby".
- Oh, wow.
- Awesome.
- Because he's also fluent in English.
He's pretty good at English.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, so he and he delivered obviously
in the English part as well
and it was really cool
because it, you know, it's
a lot of the portrayals is
all voice acting is that,
you know one person goes into the booth,
they do their lines.
Next person comes in
and that's normally how it is
but I don't know if this is
only in the Japanese industry
but at least with the anime
they put all the voice actors
that are in the one episode
all into the same room
and there are four or
five microphones lined up.
- Yeah, I saw, I saw that with some like
behind the scenes documentary.
I think how I understand the dubbing
in like the English speaking world
is that you get one
booth or one voice actor.
- It's one after the other.
- One after the other.
- But in anime it's you,
they do it all in one go.
So if there's a current
scene where there are
four voice actors, then
all four voice actors
will go up to the mics and
basically while holding
the script in the hand take it in turns
to deliver their line and when
they're not doing their line,
they pull away from the microphone.
- I think all cartoons used
to be that way in the West
but I think recently it's changed.
- I think so.
- I think one series you'd
definitely see that effect in
in is Connor Seba.
Where you can, you can tell
that all of the characters
are just like bouncing off each other.
- That helps so much.
- Unlike the dub, the dub for Connor Seba
is actually great and I
commend them for being
able to like recreate this energy
while not being in the same room because,
because you can definitely the energy
in the Japanese dub I mean, Connor Seba.
- That's what makes one events that...
- That's why it's so good
because you can tell that
these aren't just
characters that are fucking
around with one another but voice actors
that are just having
a great time together.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And you need that
dynamic in a show like that
and, but it was really cool
because with "Pop Team Epic"
you know, we would all
come onto one scene.
You know, there was me, you
know, the main voice actor
and then there was like
three or four voice actors
who were doing the, you
know just side characters.
And it was really cool because
once a scene would finish,
then if one of us needed to retake
or it was really cool because
all of the voice actors
would come together and basically critique
what we all just did in that one set.
So that we would all come together
and I would get professional
advice from the voice actor,
do you feel being like,
okay that line delivered was really cool
but maybe if you deliver
this next line like this
then I could respond in this kind of way.
- Oh, okay.
- And while all of this
conversation is happening
the voice director is also listening in.
So he can put in the input
of his writing if need be.
So, I mean, I didn't have
to do too many retakes
with "Pop Team Epic" because
the voice actor was just
like, "Yeah, that's good."
(laughs)
He just did not give a shit, right.
He was just like, yeah, good
enough. Fucking what ever.
- I mean like you, you
were speaking in English.
So he was like, yeah, this
this probably sounds better
than most of the English...
- The only time that the
voice actor asked me to do so,
the voice director asks me to
do something super specific
was when I had to do the narrator voice
for the "Guilty Gear" parody scene where
I had to say heaven or
hell like in "Guilty Gear"
and he was like, no
cause the voice director
was like a massive fan of "Guilty Gear"
so he was like, "No, no,
that's not how you say it.
You have to say it like this."
And you just broom it over the PR system.
All of us just sitting there,
"Okay, I'll do it like that I guess.
- That's always such a fan experience.
- Oh, it was super fun.
- Were you nervous doing it?
- Oh, hell yeah.
(laughs)
Because literally everybody
else around me are
professional Japanese voice
actors, but it was really cool
because all of the voice actors were like,
wow how long have you
been doing voice acting?
- I was like, this is my...
- This is my first Joey.
- Technically speaking
this is my first Joey
and they were like, "You're
really fucking good."
I was like, well, call your boy back.
- And then everyone cheered.
(laughs)
Everyone lifted Garnt up, yay.
- I was like, subscribe.
- Damn dude, oh I've had
some terrible fucking clients
when I did a lot of commercials
'cause they would bring in
like a business executive
to come in and critique and
they don't know anything.
They would, I remember
one time there was a guy
and I did this whole take,
I thought I killed it
and he was like, yeah,
something's like off with it.
This wasn't the director.
This was just the guy who
was paying for it to be made
and he was like, yeah
could you just try something different?
I did the exact same
thing again, no different
and he was like that was perfect.
(laughs)
And I was like, I was
like, I fucking knew it
'cause like, I know I might head I'm like,
I know I can get away
with doing the same thing
one more time but like
maybe not a second time.
So I was like, I'll just try once to see
if he notices, he had no idea.
At that point on with any
time he said anything.
I would just look at the
voice director over there,
I'm like I would look at him.
I'm like, should I listen to this, like.
'Cause he was the engineer
and the director of the thing.
- [Garnt] Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So he normally does the delivery,
the way, the way it was set up for me was
he normally directed me and the client
would just stand there
and go like, "Yes, yes.".
Like I was always doing business stuff,
I was like, it was like perseverance,
inspiration, shit like that.
- Did you do like a
Gillette commercial, right?
Or like a, like a
shaving cream commercial,
whatever it was.
- Something else ages ago.
I was doing like boats for like a year.
- You did boats?
- I did like, there was some, oh, I can't
I don't know what the corporation is
and I also don't know if I should say.
I don't know if I'm allowed.
I don't know what I signed.
(laughs)
Once a week I would go in for three hours
and I would talk about boats.
- Wait, how old were you?
- This was like last year?
- Oh, really?
- Every week I went in and talked about...
- This is in London, right?
- Oh, okay.
- I got paid like, like
fuck how much was it?
They were paying me 250 pounds an hour.
- Oh, wow.
- Which is like 300 something bucks.
- Yeah.
- Just talking about boats.
- Which is probably like a lot better
than what voice actors
get paid to voice anime.
- Yeah, definitely
- Yeah, anime rates aren't that great.
I mean, I don't know
if you know I'm gonna,
I'll just say like...
- I mean definitely didn't get paid.
- I have heard things and
you know, you get paid
on Funimation from what I've been told.
I don't know if this is true.
I don't know if I'm allowed
to say this, but it's not,
it's not great, it's not.
Less than what I was getting.
- Yeah, I mean, I it's
like, I think it's always
just been known that the
voice acting industry
and anime specifically just like...
- You get paid the least.
- Yeah, you get paid the
least out of any commercial
which is why you see a
lot of dub voice actors
going on to do gaming
now and other industries.
- The, the way it goes is like, it's like
normally commercials pay the most because
commercials you get
paid normally a premium
and then you also get
what's called a buyout fee.
So if your ad is going to be
played over X amount of places
with radios, TV, that gets
calculated in the cost of that
and you could get like one commercial
that takes you 20 minutes,
which it often did.
These commercials are 30
seconds long, honestly
and I would never be there
for more than 30 minutes
but they would maybe pay you
like 15 grand for the biopsy.
So your session fee was
like 250 pounds and then
you might get 15 grand or 10
depending on why they play it
and how much, because I know
the guy who did McDonald's ads
in the UK, that was his whole
career just doing McDonald's.
- [Garnt] Really.
- 'Cause you know you
get paid so fucking much.
- Yeah, it is McDonald's.
- And then used to get like
six figures, every commercial
'cause you know that's
luckily how the industry was
that you got paid if your
voice is being shared.
- Can you imagine when you're paid
six figures by going, (gibberish).
- I wish man, here's the thing.
- He was like imagine, how much,
how much money McDonald's made off of...
- Right, because the, normally
how it is with commercials
is that if your, normally with voices,
if a corporation gets one voice actor,
it's normally always that one voice actor
who does everything.
So in the industry where,
when I was in London
it was mainly commercial stuff.
So it came up a lot and
it was always like people
were competing to get
that one commercial Joey
that kept coming.
- Yeah,
- And so I got this boat Joey.
I didn't think anything of
it 'cause I didn't audition.
They like requested me. So I
went in, I did a read of it..
I was talking about,
I had to explain a ton
of different things about large ships.
(laughs)
For a corporation thing.
- [Joey] Okay.
- And I had to go in every week
and do something ballasting.
That was what, I did like four weeks
of thing called ballasting, right.
Ballasting is a thing and I know this
because I did four scripts on it.
- Okay, tell us then,
what is ballasting, sir?
- It was like, it was like,
God, I wish I remembered the words
and I remember every time
I would go into deliver it
'cause my accent is English, right
but it's not a received pronunciation
which is the typical accent, which is
I say grass, but it's grass.
So every time I would
do anything, he's like,
"You didn't, you didn't say
the receive presentation,
do it again."
I'm like, oh yes of course ballasting,
you know, is the, you know, like that
and it was basically where water goes
in the ships and they dunk
it, dump it out later on
but there was like so many
scientific words and I was like
he was the sodium hydrosis
collage oxide oxygenation thing
and I was like, all right.
And know, the hard
thing about that is that
you could do a thing called line reading
where they're paying you to
get this right first time.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So the first time I
see the script is when
I go in there.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'm sure that was that the same
for you with "Pop Team Epic"?
- No.
- You couldn't see the full hand?
- With "Pop Team Epic" I
got sent not only the script
about three weeks before I went in
but I also got a CD with.
- Fuck.
- The actual visual.
- That's like amazing.
- So I can practice this ahead of time
And apparently that's normally
in the anime industry.
- But that's just like
the Japanese trust system.
- Yeah, it's like, we trust that
you will not leak this anyway.
- That just sounds like
a leak waiting to happen,
in any other industry.
- I didn't sign a contract either.
- What, they just got to
send this without an end.
- They just sent it to me hoping
that I wouldn't leave this.
- Bro, I, I can maybe count on my hands.
The amount of time I received the script
before I got that, like,
it was like never.
- [Garnt] Really.
- Yeah, and so I would get
the script in front of me,
I'd maybe have two minutes
to quickly go over it
but they immediately expected
me to like nail it first time
and again, there's words
I've never even seen
in the English language
the company scripts, right.
I don't know what these words are
but I'm expected to like nail it
whilst I'm also reading
it for the first time
and that's what they're paying
you an absurd amount for.
- Like I, I know people who've
run like official discourse,
like...something I have to sign NDAs.
- Yeah.
- Here you are to just actually,
get getting you the
entire script before hand.
- Here's episode nine, six
months before it comes out.
(laughs)
No, it was crazy like I got it in the mail
they didn't even tell me
then we're gonna send it
because I was also assuming
that I was going to see
the script and everything
when I got there.
- Yeah, that normally how it is.
- Yeah, right that's what I heard as well.
- Dubbing do that as well.
- It's the same with dubbing.
- That's what I heard but not only that
but when I, when I also...in the
"Grisaia Phantom Trigger" game, they also
send me the script like two
weeks beforehand as well.
They didn't send me the visuals
but they sent me the script,
like the physical script
and I had to go in with
the physical script.
- I think the difference is normally
in the Western industries,
they're still editing the script.
Like the day off, like
said normally the script
that you get might not
even be the final draft,
the one that you are recording.
- It's also people don't
trust anyone in this.
Which is, which is, of course, you know,
this is, this is the country
the way you can leave
like your fucking laptop
in the middle of a diner,
go to the bathroom and then come back
and just trust that
nobody's going to take it.
- I just wanted to leak the poke stuff.
I don't even care, I just wanna leak it.
- Don't tell anybody about
the sodium hydroxide.
(laughs)
- Yeah, that it's crazy
but I mean, you know.
- Did you get paid well
for the boat thing though?
- Oh yeah, I got paid really well
but that's like that's like
the voice actors dream,
is I didn't, I didn't do
it for the money I shoot it
'cause it was fun.
- Yeah, that's same with me.
- 'Cause I feel like people
who go into especially
like the anime industry too
who wants to be a voice actor,
they do it for the passion.
- You get paid nothing for those sessions.
I mean maybe unless
you're a sag actor in LA
you get paid a decent amount.
I think it's $250 minimum for
a session, two hour session.
But yeah it's you get the notoriety,
which allows you to do a lot.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Right, I don't know
'cause I feel like nowadays
there's less notoriety
in like big voice sites names
in dubbing at least
than, than they used to.
- True, they used to be cons, right.
That's what you want It.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly
but now like if, even if
you get to voice a dub
in like a huge, huge show, there's like
you still don't get as much notoriety
as like say back in like
the mid two thousands
we had voice sites like Steve Bloom,
Johnny Yong Bosch, Crispin Freeman
who just like those
those like the triple a
voice acting voice.
- Everybody knew who they were, exactly.
But it's a lot harder in this climate
and industry just because
there's so many dubs now.
- Yeah.
- Everything gets slammed with like,
if it's on Funimation it's probably
gonna be signed with dubbed
and everyone watches anime
like very different ways now.
You know what I mean like,
like even, even going back
to "Japan Sinks" where
I didn't know who any of the voice actors
who voiced in this anime
where, because I was like,
I was literally switching
between dub and sub
depending on which one
I like to listen to.
'Cause I feel like the voice acting
for dubs in general has gotten
to like a passable quality.
- [Connor] That's great.
- And almost every show.
Like there, there, there
are some shows that are like
this is, this is just a funny dub
but for the most part if I
wanna just shut my brain off
and just listen to what
the language that I want,
that I speak then I just
I'll just put on dub
and I can, I can I have the trust
that it will be like a decent experience.
- Dub have definitely
gotten to that point, yeah.
- Yeah, there's there's certainly no like
'90s quality like hilarious dub.
- No, no.
- Yeah, which is what I
feel like the whole argument
of sub versus dub is kind
of like you to this place.
- I feel like the
counterpoint to that is that
there are less dubs
that just stand out now.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think of some
of my favorite dubs, right.
Something like "Baccano"
and "Cowboy Bebop".
You know, these are dubs that stand out.
Like literally, like I remember
how good they were just
because of how they quality but
nowadays I don't know, I can't think,
I can't think of like many
dubs that literally just,
okay, this everything's good.
Everything's decent quality
but I can't think of anything
that like truly stands out
as this is a dub experience.
- To me the last, I think the
newest, newest quote unquote
anime where the dub was like, wow
was probably "Panty & Stocking".
- Yeah, but that was like 2008.
- Yeah, that why I'm saying
(laughs)
newest in quotations.
- It's how the industry
was back then, right.
You had like two weeks
to just cast people,
like you had two weeks just for that,
let alone everything else but now,
you have two weeks to, not
even two weeks like one week,
to cast translate and get
these actors in the booth
and get a recording.
Like it's you, you can't expect
that anything good come out of that.
You can, we get the good products, right.
It's decent but we're
not gonna get anything
that blows us away from it.
- Yeah, I think the last, the last dub
that blew me away it was
probably "Stein's Gate"
because it's, it was one of
those shows where I actually,
I could appreciate the work
that went into translating
and just scripting it.
Not just like the voice
acting but like everything
was just really polished.
- I believe that was scripted by.
(murmurs).
- Yeah, the one...
- Which is why he absolutely killed it.
- That's amazing.
- Came as well, so like, because I think
with the era of dubbing, it's just
it's a lot harder to
recreate that same quality
and that same height
because they just don't have
as much time anymore.
- I also think at least for Funimation
I think when Sony took over,
I think they restructured
a lot of it to make it
less focused on giving a
writer's time and more giving,
like getting the whole thing out sooner.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which, you know, it's
understandable, I guess
but also at the same time,
you kind of lose a bit
of that magic that, you know,
maybe a double beep, whoa.
You know what I mean?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Actually here's, here's
a question for you, Garnt
'cause you, you, you could
probably judge us the best
but ever since the beginning
of time, there's always
been this debate of subs
versus dubs, you know.
The Japanese, Japanese voice
citing is always great.
Has there been any show or
any anime from your experience
that it's just bad voice acting
from like a Japanese side of things?
- Man, that's hard to say because
at least with voice, from my
understanding and my experience
at least Japanese voice acting in anime
has just had an insanely
high bar to jump over now,
even ever since even you know,
like I could obviously
go back to, you know
an enemy from the '70s.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- And probably find some
bad voice acting there
but that's because it was a
medium that was still getting
refined since the '60s.
- Yeah.
- But I think honestly,
every anime I've seen
since you know, the late '80s, early '90s,
I don't think there's been a,
maybe there's been like one
or two bad voices or one or two maybe like
under qualified voices
compared to everybody else
in that same show.
But I wouldn't say there's an entire show
that has like bad voice acting because.
- The same way that there are bad dubs...
- Yeah, exactly but, and I don't know
maybe that's like a cultural
thing, maybe it's just.
- I think it's cause
they've set up a system here
that ensures they're
getting voice talent, right.
They have schools
specifically for voice acting.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- We don't really have that in the West.
It's you go to acting school and
maybe stumbled into voiceover, right.
If that's what you like.
There's not really a system
- But their entire, you know
like four year universities...
- No right, exactly it's
the same reason why like
(murmurs) amazing at e-sports
they have the infrastructure
there to support
like making this talent.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you know, in Japan,
obviously they've been
having their schools for
awhile where the bar is
getting pushed constantly and constantly.
Whereas it's not really
like that in the West.
- Exactly.
- And you know the great thing
as well with the structure
of, at least with Japanese
voice acting and animate
is that if there is a new
voice actor or actress
that comes into the industry,
they usually start them off
with very, very small roles.
Maybe like one line or
even just background noise
to kind of get them
used to that environment
and give them as much
experience as possible
and then maybe after they
do it, you know, 10 rolls
of playing, you know,
a person passing behind
the main character after the 10th time,
then they can give them a role where...
- That's like the Japanese...
- Yeah, here's two more lines.
Okay, the next one we'll
give you five lines,
the next one we'll give you 10 lines
and then it just builds
and builds from there.
Unless if it's someone
that just has insane amount
of talent from the get-go
and they're just confident
enough to put them
into a show and then they
make a name for themselves.
- Some of the best performances
have been from actors
where like they weren't acting
in any other animated shows.
- Oh, no yeah.
I think, I think, I
think Johnny Yong Bosch
like stumbled into his
first dub role by accident.
I think same would Steve Bloom as well.
- Yeah, I think so.
- Yeah.
- From what I probably remember.
- It's been a while since
I heard the stories.
- Both fantastic voice acts.
- God, I think it was the guy who did
light in (murmurs),
he did a lot of the ocean
dubs in Canada, he did like...
- 'Cause he did Rock from
"Black Lagoon" as well.
- I think he was doing
"My Little Pony" before.
- Really?
- Or he did after, I think he did after
but before that I think
he'd done anything,
I knew the guy voices was
elaborate so and back in though,
I hadn't done any anime.
- No, no I remember a
lot of like back then,
a lot of the voice actors
he voiced in "Baccano"
was that, that was like the first roll.
- Yeah.
- Because everyone fucking
killed it, you know.
- It's really, there's a
lot of unknown voice actors
and actresses in that, in our show.
- [Connor] Great show
- Yeah, questions to you,
questions to you guys then,
we've so we've the ridiculously
high bar that Japanese voice acting has.
What, what are some shows that you know,
that even stand up for you with like the
Japanese voice talent
and the voice acting?
I'll tell you the show that
stands out to me most recently
and that's "Beastars".
- [Garnt] Oh, yeah.
- "Beastars" has absolutely
like insane voice acting
and it's a very different
because it doesn't,
it didn't sound like your typical
anime kind of voice acting,
it sounded very grounded.
- I don't know who the
voice actor for "Legacy" is,
but his his acting was so good.
- That was so good.
- Like "Legacy" and "Lewis".
- Yeah.
- Was like, they both had like
the voice acting performances
of that year, in any anime.
- Oh, easily, easily.
- In my, in my opinion,
like even, even with shows
like "Attack on Titan Three" coming out
that had some great voice.
I think I still think "Beastars" was like
just a cut above the rest.
- I think it's just because
"Beastars" as a show
was just a cut above the rest.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like it was just such
a fucking amazing show.
- I'm trying to think
of any Japanese shows
that really blew me
away with voice acting.
- "Jojo"?
(laughs)
I mean, my man Dio kills
it...like that performance.
I spoke about it before,
like his performance
like this Dio, like I'm
not in memes a side like,
it's fucking amazing.
- Oh, yeah.
- He's fucking great.
- And everyone in part five,
I would argue as well
has fantastic voices.
I think the thing with
Japanese voice as well is that
they can just do casting so well.
- Yeah, they get it.
- Like they understand how important
casting is for our character.
- Oh, I'm working on a video right now.
I'm like, I've watched the "Clannad" dub
and there is one scene
where a female teacher
is just voiced by a dude.
(laughs)
- What?
- Yeah, like I'm it's I
obviously can't show this
but I'll show you guys later...
- I mean, this is why
I didn't watch a dog.
(laughs)
- It just like a scene
and I watched it damn,
I don't remember this but I
watched someone sent me the clip
and I'm like, that's just a dude.
(laughs)
kind of like, "Hi boys."
"Like that, how're you doing?
I'll get this pass." all right.
- I mean there's a lot of
weird things that happened
with dubbing back in the day.
We're gonna talk about bad dubs,
you know what I mean.
- Yeah, exactly.
You know, we have to talk about, you know,
like "Ghost Stories" and stuff like that.
- "Ghost Stories" is that a
bad dub or is that just...
- It's so bad that it's good dub.
- People always act, 'cause
when I, when I tweet up,
you're like, hey I'm
gonna fix bad anime scenes
for a YouTube video,
people always be like,
yeah, fixed "Ghost Stories".
I'm like, what is there to fix?
- There's nothing to fix.
- That thing is amazing.
- It's fucking great.
- Is it's just 'cause, from
what I've heard about how
"Ghost Stories" came to be
made, it was "Ghost Stories"
just sold horribly in Japan.
So when they'd licenses, licensing over,
they were like do what you
need to do to make this sell.
Like, dude you have.
- There is some rules,
there is some rules.
- Creative control, yeah,
there was some rules.
Where you basically, you basically
had full creative control
and from what I heard like,
they were just, the voice
actors would just try to rush in
the booth first and they would
just like add live the scenes
and everyone else would have to like play
off what they said.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It was like the first of bridge.
- Yeah, essentially
- Essentially.
- I mean, yeah it's, it's
weird to think right,
that dubs back in the '70s were done,
there was no email.
Like how did they do this?
There was literally a
guy was given this DVD
and they would just kind of made it
and he just had the jacket.
- They just figure it out.
- Just hope they did it
well, like it's weird, right.
Do you think there was...
- Even then, there was a trial system.
- Yeah, it's just so weird.
You know like I guess just take this DVD
and go home, VHS, Betamax.
- DVD, what existed before DVD?
- Take this cassette.
(laughs)
- Laser disk.
- Yeah, laser disk.
Laser disk never took off in the West
but in Japan, they were like,
God, yeah, no, it's weird.
But even then I think
that's also why some dubs
now are a bit strange
'cause they were still done
on that system where if
you go first, you dub it
and then the person who
comes next has to dub
but they get to hear just your character
who's been before you, so.
It was last, normally is easiest time.
- Right, and that because
they have to kind of go along
with oh, they perform this
character in this way.
So I kind of have to do it the same
but if the first one sucks.
- It's a bit unfortunate 'cause
I think it makes this weird
kind of feeling sometimes by accident
but this is again, why
a director should be
on top of that show.
- Yeah, that's, that's
what, that's why like
the director has control
over how this sounds
'cause there are
definitely some dubs where
it definitely sounds like people
aren't having a conversation.
- Yeah.
- A voice over, I think a
director's job is like 10%
to get the best performance out of you
and like 90% to make sure everyone sounds
like they're in the same world.
Like that's the hardest part
'cause you're constantly thinking like,
okay that was a great line
but does it fit with what
the other person just delivered?
Like I need to think about that.
- Yeah, it's a really hard skill.
It's definitely hard 'cause
you have to be on top
of what everyone is saying
and how everyone's sounds
and it's, it's definitely like,
you can definitely see some of the nuances
that people don't normally
think about but if you
if you play a conversation
and it's just like,
man these people just sound
like they're reading lines
to each other and not actually
having a conversation.
And it's really, it just
sounds it's the uncanny valley.
- Yeah, it sounds like they're kind of
talking through dimensions.
(laughs)
One's living in one
world and the other one's
living in the other world then
the rift just happened to open
up where it's like, oh hello.
(laughs)
- Hello, hi Mark.
- Hi, Mark.
- God, I could sit here
and talk all day about
dubbed anime and voice acting and all that
'cause obviously that's
what I'm cripplingly
addicted to that and all that shit.
- Probably not music.
- Yeah.
- Not music.
- We're gonna get this boy on some like,
we gotta make him understand emotions use,
I never thought I'd say that.
- I just, I wish like
I wish Kevin was here.
I wish Kevin was like
guessing in this one episode.
- I think Kevin can convince
me but like this is...
- No, no I just wanna, I
just wanna see his reaction
when you were just saying all this
stuff as a fucking composer.
Kevin if you're watching this,
I want you to just like,
if if we ever get Kevin
on the show and we will
get Kevin on the show,
just, I want to just
hear the conversation...
- I'll dead ass look him in the eye.
- I want you to dead
ass look him in the eye
and just be like, "Made
in Abyss" soundtrack
made me feel good.
- I'll do it.
- Just dead ass looking
at me and just be like,
I don't remember any of your music
but it made me feel good.
(laughs)
- I heard it, I heard the sounds.
- I mean, I feel like I
have the opposite brain
to like a composer though
in like every aspect,
like when I talked to Kevin, I feel
like I'm on like the complete
opposite mind in every way.
It's crazy, it's so weird.
I think I just have
that, that kind of mind
that isn't, isn't like that.
- I mean, if we can't even like relate to,
we're not exactly composers.
- I feel like you're, you're
very musical though, right.
- I mean, yeah, but I'm no Kevin Penkin.
- No right, but you have
an appreciation for music
something that I don't have.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I can't make music, it
doesn't make sense to me.
I don't understand any of that.
Like I tried to learn drums as a kid
and I was like, yes,
this just doesn't work.
- Do you follow along with like different
animate directors and like?
- If you say their names, maybe.
- So if I said Hosoda Mamoru?
- No.
- If I said Shinkai Makoto?
- Yes.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- Your name.
(laughs)
I know that one.
- Wait, you don't know Hosoda Mamoru??
- No.
- Have you never seen "Wolf Children"?
- [Garnt] "Summer Wars".
- [Connor] I've seen "Summer Wars".
- The "Digimon Movie"
- I didn't watch that, who the fuck
watched the "Digimon Movie"
- The "Digimon Movie" is fucking awesome.
- I'm joking, I'm joking.
Don't kill me, "Summer Wars" and.
- "Boy and the Beast"?
- "Boy and the Beast".
- He also did a "One Piece" movie.
- What's the jumping
through time or something.
- Oh, "The Girl Who Leapt Through Time"
- Yeah, what's that one?
- He also did you know, he also directed
"The Samurai Champloo Opening?"
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Okay, he also directed a
"One Piece" movie as well.
"One Piece" movie, six, I think.
- That was such good fucking movie.
- I know, that was fucking great.
- I loved it.
- Did you watch the "Digimon Movie" movie,
when you were a kid?
- Yeah.
- Do you remember the soundtrack for that?
- Yes.
- The hard fucking bare naked ladies,
and "Less Than Jake"
- Yeah, so good.
- Fatboy Slim, like
whoa is this soundtrack.
- It was screaming '90s.
Like it ain't...do you remember
that scene was all star?
Fucking all star in it.
- What?
- Yeah, I'm totally serious.
- Fucking smash mouth.
- He had smash mouth.
- How do they get these rights?
- Because he was back in the day.
It was like back in the
day of like '90s movies.
It wasn't like they had a
completely different sound track
from the Japanese release.
- Yeah.
- So when they, when they
like dubbed it westernized
there they put all of
these like Western bands.
- I couldn't because I watched
the Japanese movie first,
obviously but then I
went to a friend's place
and he only had the dub for it.
I was like, I've never seen the dubs.
I might as well, watch it
and then when I heard
Smashmouth I was like,
you was playing a prank on me?
(laughs)
Did you overdub this was Shrek.
- I want to now just watch this movie,
Gesture experience "Smash
Mouth" and Fatboy Slim,
- Hearing Fatboy slim
I was like, what was...
- It was so surreal.
- Yeah, it was cause I didn't
realize how special was
when I was watching as a
kid, but now growing up
I think back and I realized,
man this was a really weird, sounds...
- It's like turning up
to like kindergarten.
They've got Coke on the table.
(laughs)
All right, I would do this.
- Fatboy slim song, was it?
- Right here, right now.
- It was that or was it weapon of choice?
- I think it was a weapon of choice.
- Yeah, it was weapon of choice.
- It was weapon of choice.
- Just hearing weapon of
choice in "Digimon Movie"
- Dude just hearing Fatboy Slim,
like takes me back 10 years.
- I fucking love fat boy slim dude.
- Fatboy slim is fucking great.
- From Brighton by the way,
as a born and bred
Brightonian, yeah from my home.
Any famous people from
where you're from Connor?
- I think there was a
Lost Profits, that band
but then I think they
were like pedophiles, so.
We quickly, quickly abandoned that word.
(laughs)
There was a band called Leo,
it's called Lost Profits
and I think they were like
a fucking, I don't know.
They were like kind of like
a knockoff of like some way.
- I think I remember the Lost Profits.
Were like the rock band that like was
like British fallout boys sort of ish.
- Like panic at the disco kind of vibe.
- A little more Rocky I think of but yeah.
- Oh, okay I was actually,
I was watching a new anime
recently have you guys heard
of "The Great Pretender"?
- I have heard of it, yes.
- Song?
- No, no the anime, the anime.
- There's there's an anime
called the "Great Pretender".
Fucking, I've only seen
the first three episodes.
It's like a Netflix exclusive anime
but it seems like it's,
it's fucking great.
- I saw a preview for
that, I wanna watch that.
- It's a heist show that sets in America.
Yeah, exactly you're
like when you think of
heist show in anime I think
of "Lupin The Third", right.
Like this I can't think
of many other heist shows
but they actually, the
ending for that song
is the "Great Pretender"
by Freddie Mercury.
I remember watching it, I
was like, wow, who is this?
This kind of sounds like...
And I saw, I don't know.
See is the actual "Great
Pretender" by Freddie Mercury.
- Fuck how did the get that?
- I know, right, I know.
- I sometimes wonder that because there's,
there's a few anime series where
they've gotten Western songs, right, like.
- "Paradise Kiss".
- Franz Ferdinand, yeah.
- Did they?
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Paradise Kiss"
- Do you want to
by Franz Ferdinand?
- No.
- Yeah, and you know
like "Egre Proxy" ending,
was paranoid Andrew, by Radiohead and,
"Eden of the East", had "Oasis"
- Yeah, that was surreal.
- That had such a good
opening, the holy shit.
- "Eden of the East" opening as someone.
- That was a great show.
- That was a very good
show but the opening to me
out of everything stands of the most.
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause it's probably one of my favorite
openings of all time.
- You know what I mean, you
know, we're in a good mood
when either gone on, I put that on karaoke
were just like, oh, let's go baby.
(laughs)
It's such a good song.
- It's great because
these are like the songs
that I could put on on the karaoke
and just pretend like I can sing.
- This is an anime song.
- I'm a weep...
- Like when was the last time,
that an anime had like
a Western song in it?
Like the whole "Great Pretender" was it,
was it a "Erge Proxy"?
- It might've been one of those.
- There's been a lot.
- There's gotta be some, I don't know.
- Yeah, I don't know if there's like,
I can't think of my head like
how many actual English songs,
'cause there's, there's
been Japanese songs
or there's been Japanese
bands that have sunk English.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- In terms of actual pure
here is like a Western band
who, who is just got to got a song...
- There was also that anime from like the
early 2000s I just remember that
Duran Duran song as the opening.
- Oh yeah, the was.
- What the fuck was that...
- That, that was, that was...
- It was the camera one.
The camera on, yeah.
- What the fuck was it?
It was girls on a film by Duran Duran.
(murmurs).
(laughs)
- "Speed Grapher".
- "Speed Grapher"
- "Speed Grapher", "Speed Grapher"
- That was the one.
- "Speed Grapher" had Duran Duran.
- Unlike cereal experiments
lane as well had this
that had this like really weird unique,
British indie bands that had Dove.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What the fuck?
- Connor is jus sitting here being like,
what's what's going on.
- I've watched like half these shows
and I'm like, oh yeah, they did have that.
- Oh, my God.
- I just forget.
- How could you forget.
- Because I listen to them
like, oh, that's cool.
(laughs)
I'm gonna forgetting on my day.
- Dude do you skip opening...
- After one watch, after
one, one opening view
I'm like, unless it was "Beastars",
I watched it every time.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- She was like...
- Actually, actually
very specifically then
do you ever, okay do you
ever notice that moment
in any anime where it's
a really hype scene
and they play the opening song?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, good if you notice
that, then you're not,
you're not completely brain dead.
- You're not completely brain dead.
- That's like saying the name
of the show to me. (laughs)
- It's like, I loved
like, I don't know why
it always works, right but.
- [Connor] No, it's hype.
- It's type, you, you
play the opening song
in any hype scene and it just brings
it from like a 10 to a 20.
(laughs)
- It does, it does.
- It's pretty fucking hype.
They're about to pop off.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
Or like, you know, you
know, shit's gone down
when it's the end of the
episode and like the end,
the ending song start playing.
- Before it's finished.
- And you're like, oh shit,
shit's about to go down.
Shit's about to get real.
- It's like PTSD of the "Anahata" song,
that's always playing
and I'm like, no, no, no.
- I had that with, I had that with,
fucking (murmurs).
When the fucking, when the chorus starts.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Every time it like, every
episode opens with that
but then there are a few
episodes near the end.
- Is that a bush name?
- Yeah, from the future world,
it's like really good.
It's 10 out of 10 coming
but the opening that series
didn't have an opening.
It just had like this
chorus of kids just going.
- I was about to say like sarcastic.
Yeah, I really liked the opening to that.
(laughs)
- That's the opening.
- I really love when I circulate.
(laughs)
- Hey man, that's a great opening.
No okay, I remember right.
I watched 'cause I downloaded
all of "Bakemonogatari"
I watched them all and I
remember I listened to,
I circulation, I thought,
wow, that's a fucking tune.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I went to find it,
I thought, man, am I the
only guy who likes this song?
(laughs)
- Found out like two hours later
literally everyone loves this song.
It made like the meme compilations.
- I'm gonna give a hot take though,
it's not my favorite one on
guitar opening, platinum disco.
- Platinum disco.
- Yeah, platinum disco.
Platinum disco is really fucking great.
- That fucking dance is,
so good.
- I feel like "Monogatari" has
like so many banger opening
and endings as well.
- Oh, yeah even the first
opening of "Bakemonogatari".
- Yeah, yeah staples.
- Yeah, staples.
- That was like.
- That's was like the
great fucking song too.
- "Dorohedoro" changed
the ending every time?
- I don't know.
- And then "Beastars" did.
- Beastars changed the ending,
I think "Dorohedoro" did as well
and they were really, really fucking good.
- Yeah, because we have them
on a "Monogatari" series.
He was the first time when I noticed
they were actually Changing the endings,
like to every all arc, every
arc in a different ending.
I thought that was like...
- Every arch had a
different opening, as well.
- Yeah, that's true.
I thought he was like a really nice touch.
- Yeah.
- Like little things like that.
- That "Monogatari" policy.
- 'Cause I know there
have been other series
that have done that but I think of any
off the top of my head.
- There's a ton I'm sure but
I need to write shit down.
I think that's what I've
taken away from this episode.
How'd the music make me feel,
I should write more than one word.
- I would, I wouldn't
like a thousand word essay
on how music in anime makes you feel
by the end of this episode.
(laughs)
- Let me give a presentation
of why I like music in anime.
- Seeing you process, like try to process,
how music makes you feel is one of like,
the most eyeopening moments I've ever seen
for you as a friend, just like.
- I'm looking forward to
the meme of this, man.
- I'm gonna get...
I'm ready to get fucking roasted
by the viewers of this episode.
But it's fine I know I,
I big brain in some things
monkey brain than others.
- Big brain in chess,
goldfish brain and music.
(laughs)
- Combined this, combined
with with the fucking
video game episode where,
I'm gonna be like, literally
everyone's getting...
- I don't like listening to music,
I don't wanna read.
I just want to play chess,
that's Connor in a nutshell.
- Yeah, I guess what the is
going on with my brain, man.
- Yeah, I don't know, it's weird, man.
- Is there anything
else you guys wanna talk
about for this episode?
- I don't think so.
- I think we've, we've covered...
- Here are the lovely patrons
on the screen right now.
- Yeah, thank you very much
to the patrons for
helping us support this.
- Shout out to those, guys.
That's great guys.
This guys are my favorite guys.
(laughs)
- How do those guys make you feel?
- Yeah, how do the patrons make you...
- Good.
(laughs)
Sad, happy.
- Also, if you want to stick around and
figure out what we're doing off YouTube
and Spotify and whatnot
then you can also follow us
on Twitter at TrashTastePod
and we also have a subreddit
where you guys give us
plenty of dank memes.
We always check...
- [Connor] We always check
the subreddit, we always
check the Twitter so.
- At the moment of this recording,
it's just full of chess memes.
- Lots of chess memes, lots of great
of fucking fan art as
well, we've been getting.
- Yeah, a lot of people wondering
how we record our episodes
we are a little ahead at the moment
but that's because we're eventually
gonna travel at some point.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You need to get a little backlog going.
- [Garnt] Exactly, exactly.
- Yeah, I'm the boy and thank
you for watching this episode
of "Trash Taste" with the two other boys.
- Boy two and boy three.
- They make me feel happy,
good and I've been, man.
- Thank you very much, man.
- Thank you man.
- What's wrong with me
man, what's wrong with me.
My mom's gonna think
what happened to my boy.
(laughs)
- Join us next episode, where
we teach man how to make fire.
(laughs)
- What's that channel
called with like prime.
- Primitive technology.
- Primitive music featuring Connor,
we're gonna teach him the xylophone.
- It's gonna be our goal just
to see like the evolution
of Connor as this podcast goes along.
From like caveman, to
like sophisticated human.
- Here's what's gonna happen.
Next time I watch a show,
I'm gonna make note of the soundtrack
and how it makes me feel,
in more than one line.
- Yeah, in more than one word.
- Yeah, we'll see you guys next time.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)